So, wer das noch nicht mitsingen kann, dann ist das die Hausaufgabe bis zur nächsten Woche. Kraftwerk, Numbers oder aber Zahlen im Blue Moon am 30. Januar, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Das heißt Chaos Radio mit Konstanze, mit Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, einen wunderbaren guten Abend. Wir sind in Teil 131. Es geht heute um das großartige Thema Ausbruch aus dem Panoptischen Gefängnis. Was das eigentlich sein soll, erklären wir gleich. Vorher aber, wenn wir den Chaos Computer Club schon mal zu Gast haben, müssen wir natürlich darüber reden, dass in Hessen gerade gewählt wurde und dass dort auch Wahlcomputer eingesetzt werden sollten. Ihr Thema, Constanze.
Na ja, wir hatten da ziemlich viel Spaß in Hessen. Denn wir hatten uns ja, nachdem die Klage vom hessischen Staatsgerichtshof aus formalen Gründen ja zurückgewiesen wurde, also der Antrag auf eine Anordnung, dass die Wahlcomputer nicht eingesetzt werden, haben wir uns entschlossen, da großflächig Wahlbeobachtung zu machen und waren damit über 50 Leuten im Einsatz und haben uns überall in den Gemeinden, also acht Stück, acht Gemeinden in Hessen angeguckt, wie denn eigentlich diese Wahlcomputer tatsächlich im Gebrauch und in der Verwendung dann behandelt werden. Also ob diese sogenannten geschützten Umgebungen eingehalten werden und...
Weil wir kurz festhalten müssen, für alle, die beim Thema Wahlcomputer machen, Wahlcomputer ist i, bä, pfui, erg, böse, böse.
Wenn du es mal so zusammenfassen möchtest...
Wie möchte ich folgstümlich zusammenfassen, Wahlcomputer ist i, g, d, gitt?
Ja, wir haben ein kleines Problem mit diesen Wahlcomputern eigentlich nur weil niemand sehen kann, wie die Stimmen tatsächlich dann zusammengezählt werden und wie das Ergebnis zustande kommt. Jedenfalls haben wir da festgestellt in Hessen, dass diese sogenannten gesicherten Umgebungen einfach nicht der Realität entsprechen und dass vor allen Dingen massiv versucht wurde, die Wahlbeobachtung zu unterbinden. Teilweise eben mit Androhung der Polizei und so ein übereifriger Ordnungsbeamter raste dann noch hinterher mit dem Auto hinter unseren Wahlbeobachtern und hat die bis zur Autobahn verfolgt. Wir haben sogar einen langen so einen Fall, wo der vom CCC gewarnt wurde schriftlich vorab in so einem Brief, wo also alle 20 Wahllokale vor den bösen bösen CCC-Leuten gewarnt wurden. Dabei haben wir natürlich nichts gestört, sondern eben nur ganz in Ruhe beobachtet. Und wir haben natürlich auch festgestellt vor allen Dingen, dass in der einen Gemeinde Niedernhausen diese Wahlcomputer in der Nacht davor bei den Parteimitgliedern, die auch gleichzeitig Wahlvorsteher sind, privat gelagert wurden.
Die haben sozusagen mit denen geschlafen.
Mit den kleinen Wahlcomputern im Bett.
Mehr möchte ich eigentlich gar nicht wissen. Zu dem Thema, die nächsten Wahlen, die anstehen, wo auch das Thema Wahlcomputer wieder mal auftauchen wird, ist Hamburg, richtig? Die haben im Februar Landtagswahlen?
Nee, in Hamburg hat sich ja gegen den digitalen Wahlstift entschieden.
Stimmt, die hatten den Wahlstift.
Am 9. März ist Schwerin oben?
Nee, ich glaube erst mal Wittenberge. Genau, aber wir haben noch eine Stichwahl in Hessen, nämlich am 10. Februar. Und wer da noch Lust hat, kann sich da gerne unser Wahlcomputer Wiki eintragen und danach mitbeobachten. Das ist ein großer Spaß.
Das ist zu finden unter anderem auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de Also zumindest gibt es da alle weiteren Links, die ihr finden müsst. Und damit sind wir beim Thema der heutigen Sendung, nämlich Ausbruch aus dem panoptischen Gefängnis. Ja, eigentlich geht es um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die uns alle, egal wo ihr euch jetzt gerade befindet, ob in der Badewanne oder beim Zähneputzen oder vom Fernseher oder beim Parkplatz suchen oder aber bei der Arbeit oder sonst wo betreffen. Denn seit 1. Januar werden alle Kommunikationsdaten, die wir so verursachen, gespeichert und ausgewertet. Verbindungsdaten, entschuldigen, möchte natürlich da die Präzision waren. Und das sind Geschichten, die man eigentlich nicht cool findet. Es ist aber jetzt Gesetz und wir müssen seit einem Monat damit leben. Und wir würden gerne von euch wissen, wie geht ihr eigentlich damit um und wie geht es euch damit? Das könnt ihr, eure Meinung könnt ihr kundtun, entweder am Telefon unter der 0331 70 97 110 oder aber im Chaosradio Chat. Aber Telefon wäre natürlich schöner, weil dann können alle anderen zuhören.
Genau, genau.
Und wir wollen ein bisschen erzählen, wie man denn eigentlich ja, wie man damit leben kann und wie man es vielleicht auch den Behörden ein bisschen schwerer machen kann, wie man selbst seine Anonymität ein bisschen wahren kann, wie man sich nicht nur sicher, sondern auch ein bisschen, wenigstens ein bisschen anonym im Netz bewegen kann und ja, ein paar kleine Tipps geben und auch vielleicht mit ein paar Mythen aufräumen. Es gab ja ein paar sehr kreative Ideen dazu in letzter Zeit, wie man das Ganze vielleicht umgehen könnte. Die wollen wir mal beleuchten, schauen, ob die wirklich so effektiv sind und so viel bringen oder ob das vielleicht doch eigentlich eine blöde Idee ist.
Stichwort diese SIM-Karten-Tauschbörse, die es mal eine Weile gab, die für im ersten Moment ganz lustig ist, aber wenn man weiter darüber nachdenkt, gibt es eine Menge Fußnoten, über die kann man durchaus reden. Wir werden reden mit euch auch über verschlüsselte Surfen im Internet. Wir werden reden über verschlüsselte E-Mails. Wie sinnvoll ist das Ganze? Aber vielleicht sollten wir am Anfang, um das nochmal so ein bisschen aufzurollen, erklären, was sind das eigentlich für Daten, die jetzt genau gespeichert werden? Also wenn ihr mit dem Handy telefoniert und irgendjemand anruft, dann wird gespeichert, ihr habt telefoniert und zwar von der Handyzelle so und so an diesem Ort mit der und der Nummer für die und die lange Zeit und die andere Nummer ist diese und jene. Und das ist dann für im Moment offiziell sechs Monate nachprüfbar.
Genau.
Ja, bei dem Handy ist natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr. Dadurch, dass man ja die Funkzelle hat, hat man damit auch gleichzeitig eine geografische Position.
Das meine ich gerne, der Ort dazu ist gleich mit.
Und da kommt noch was dazu, nämlich die Anrufe, die man nur versucht hat und die nicht erfolgreich waren.
Also wenn ich sozusagen viermal versuche, meinen Rechtsanwalt anzurufen, dann könnte irgendjemand sagen, der Kranz hat doch garantiert irgendwas da.
Also beim Handy ist auch noch dazu gekommen, dass jetzt in diesem sogenannten Call Data Record, also quasi der Datei, die die Daten zu dem Anruf enthält, auch noch die Zell ID, also von der Funkzelle, wo man ist, am Ende des Gesprächs gespeichert wird.
Wir erklären es gerade so in die blaue Welt hinein. Thorsten hat gerade angerufen aus Berlin. Ich glaube, Thorsten will genau wissen, was Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich ist. Hallo Thorsten, guten Abend. Du bist jemand, der benutzt ein Telefon zur Kommunikation unter anderem. Hast du einen Computer? Auch. Benutzt du ein Internet? Benutzt du E-Mails? Hast du ein Festnetz? Hast du einen Faustkeil und eine Schieferplatte? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Das heißt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung betrifft dich im Speziellen. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, würdest du gerne wissen, was das eigentlich ist. Also die Sachen mit dem Telefon haben wir ja gerade versucht zu erklären. Das ist soweit angekommen.
Weiter geht's, wenn ich Gespräche übers Mobiltelefon vornehme, es geht nur darum, welche Zeiten, wann ich wen angerufen habe. Es geht nicht um Inhalte.
Nee, da sitzt im Moment noch keiner und schreibt das mit. Nee, aber der Rest ist schon nachprüfbar, dass du heute zum Beispiel um was weiß ich, sage ich mal 17.23, viermal mit irgendeiner Nummer in Buchs de Hude telefoniert hast und das steht für die nächsten sechs Monate in irgendeiner Art Datei.
Beim Handy kommt dann natürlich auch noch SMS dazu, also wenn man SMS-Daten verschickt und was noch beim Handy dazukommt, ist die Art des Protokolls, das man benutzt, also sozusagen der Dienst, der angeboten ist.
Also es ist interessant, wenn du Datenübertragung machst, das heißt, wenn du im Internet übers Mobiltelefon benutzt, also GPRS oder UMTS, dann wird es natürlich auch vermerkt und dann wird auch dementsprechend da deine IP-Adresse registriert, die du hattest.
Kann ich eigentlich, die werden ja bei meinem Provider gespeichert. Mein Provider muss ja sozusagen die für sechs Monate hinterlegen.
Die sogenannten Verpflichteten heißen die. Das sind also die, für die das Gesetz gilt. Und die sind auch dafür nicht nur verantwortlich, diese Daten, sag ich mal, zu erheben, sondern sie müssen auch noch speichern und vor allem auch archivieren und auch rechtssicher archivieren.
Kann ich jetzt als Jakob Kranz bei meinem Mobilfunkanbieter anrufen und sagen, hallo, guten Tag, ich bin jetzt bei Ihnen seit, sagen wir mal, am 1. Juli. Ich möchte jetzt gerne bestätigt haben, dass meine Verbindungsdaten der letzten sechs Monate gelöscht werden. Und die schicken mir eine Bestätigung, so ist das auch nicht, ne?
Interessante Idee.
So könnte man es zum Beispiel machen.
Die Geschichte, wenn ein Verdacht auf irgendwas kommt, sind denn die Daten, die dabei übertragen wurden, einsehbar?
Ja, also das ist ja die Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung regelt natürlich auch.
Telefon draußen.
Wie denn diese Daten verwendet werden dürfen. Willst du erst rangehen? Okay, sag mal nochmal. Das Gesetz zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung regelt natürlich auch, wer, also welche Behörde unter welchen Umständen und mit welcher Begründung Zugriff auf diese Daten hat und Zugang zu diesen Daten bekommt. Wer die Diskussion vielleicht ein bisschen mitverfolgt hat. Es gab darüber eine sehr große Diskussion, ob dann auch zum Beispiel die Musikindustrie, also Stichwort Tauschbörsen, Filme im Netz, ob die da drauf Zugriff bekommen, was natürlich erst mal eine ziemlich große Panik bei vielen Leuten ausgelöst hat.
Was die am liebsten haben würden.
Natürlich, also wenn die Daten da sind, dann gibt es auch irgendwie die Begehren danach. Das heißt also, die wollen die dann haben, weil da sind sie ja, und es wäre ja auch irgendwie Quatsch, wenn die jetzt dann einfach nicht verwendet werden. Derzeit ist es aber so, da hat sich zumindest unsere Frau Zyprista stark gemacht, unsere Justizministerin, dass es erstmal nicht so ist. Ich würde jetzt keinen Kasten Bier darauf verwetten, dass es in drei Jahren immer noch so ist. Aber derzeit ist erstmal derstande Diskussion, dass man also wirklich bis nur für einen Zusammenhang mit schweren Straftaten verwendet werden oder abgefragt werden dürfen.
Interessant zum Beispiel ist ja auch der Aspekt, wir haben in zwei Jahren Bundestagswahlen. Was wäre denn, wenn wir eine neu zusammengesetzte Regierung haben und die dann sagt, ja, das war aber die große Koalition, wir sehen das ganz anders. Und wir ändern jetzt dieses Gesetz, die Daten sind dann schon da. Das sind jetzt natürlich ungelegte Eier, über die man redet, aber...
Wissen wir mal, wir uns doch die nächste Regierung aussuchen wegen der Wahlcomputer.
Warte mal, am Telefon ist... Thorsten, du bleibst dran, wir haben Patrick am Telefon, der hat eine Frage, die damit anknüpft. Namen Patrick. Deine Frage geht da irgendwie mit rein, über das, worüber wir gerade reden, um Chaosradio auf Fritz, ne?
Genau, und zwar würde ich halt gern wissen, inwiefern oder wie leicht die Daten halt für den Staat verfügbar sind.
Per Mausklick sozusagen, falls du das meinst, oder was wir jetzt tun müssen.
Na, welche Daten wurden ja mehr oder weniger schon geklärt, aber es ist halt wirklich so leicht, dass dann einfach irgendwie der Beamte xy an den Rechner sitzt und meine Daten abruft, oder wie?
Ja, er sagt dann wann wohin, aber was ist die Frage?
Na guck mal, bei denen, die Telefonverbindungen, Mobilfunkverbindungen haben wir gerade geklärt. Also die können sehen, wann du versucht hast, wen anzurufen, wo du gewesen bist, beziehungsweise wie lange du telefoniert hast, wie viele SMS du geschickt hast, an welche Verbindungsdingen und welche Daten du über dein Mobiltelefon per GPS oder UMTS, also über dein Mobilfunk-Internet, abgerufen hast. Es steht da noch nicht drin, dass du gesagt hast, Mutti, brauchst du heute Abend keine Kartoffeln machen, ich hab ne andere.
Natürlich kann nicht jeder Polizeibeamte an irgendeinem Computer sitzen und die abrufen, sondern gibt natürlich rechtliche Voraussetzungen, wer die wann nutzen kann. Zunächst mal werden die erstmal gespeichert. Und für den Fall, dass man sich eben eine Straftat verdächtig macht oder auf andere Weise unter Verdacht gerät, dann kann an diese Daten eben von Seiten der Behörden rangegangen werden.
Also Patrick, du siehst es mit einem eindeutigen vielleicht zu beantworten.
Also wobei die Idee, dass ein Beamter sitzt an seinem Rechner und da ein paar Sachen zusammenklickt, die ist insofern schon richtig, als dass es definierte Abfrageschnittstellen dafür auch gibt. Also da läuft zumindest europaweit auch gerade eine Standardisierung, dass es also nicht nur innerhalb eines Landes ein einheitliches System ist, sondern europaweit, dass also die Behörden quasi über die europaweiten Telekommunikationsdaten praktisch surfen können. Es gibt aber zumindest für Deutschland schon noch eine gewisse Schranke, also das muss also schon auch noch richterlich abgesegnet sein, derzeit noch immer mit der Einschränkung. Alles, was wir sagen, ist jetzt sozusagen der aktuelle Stand der Gesetzgebung. Gerade wenn es um die technischen Details geht, das ist also auch eine wichtige Sache vorweg. Es gibt noch keine technische Richtlinie. Das bedeutet also, es gibt jetzt bei dem Gesetz oder das Gesetz ist jetzt das, was die Juristen gemacht haben. Die haben zwar so im Groben gesagt, was sie gern hätten, wenn es dann aber in die Details geht, in die Feinheiten, dann muss man muss man schon noch mal die Techniker fragen. Also wie definiere ich jetzt eigentlich eine E-Mail oder z.B. ein E-Mail-Abruf, was ist das eigentlich genau technisch? Oder wenn ich jetzt auch sage, ich will z.B. ein Chat oder irgendwelche Messenger-Geschichten mit protokollieren, was ist eigentlich Messenger und so Geschichten? Also das sind so ein paar Feinheiten, wo jetzt auch gerade noch die Service Provider so ein bisschen auf glühenden Kohlen sitzen. Die einzigen, die einigermaßen klar Schiff haben, sind die Telefonanbieter und Internetanbieter. Aber alles, was mit Diensten, also nicht mit Zugängen, sondern mit Diensten im Netz zu tun hat, gibt es noch eine ganz, ganz große Unklarheit und deswegen ist da auch die Einführung oder die verpflichtende Umsetzung erst mal noch bis Anfang 2009 verzögert.
Was ja auch ein Grund ist, warum so viele Leute Fragen dazu haben oder auch eine Meinung dazu haben, müssen mehr oder weniger, aber das betrifft uns ja alle, weil das Gesetz ist da, aber so über die genaue Umsetzung hat sich niemand so wirklich ein Copy macht. Also bis zum Ende...
Kopf schon, aber es gibt halt noch keine klaren Regeln.
Na ja, okay, also das ist das, was ich damit eigentlich sagen wollte. Also das Gesetz ist erst mal da, aber wie es bis ins Detail durch funktioniert, das ist noch nicht bis zum Ende durchdacht, bzw. bis zum Ende durchgeplant. Dann kommen aber schon wieder die ersten Leute, die sagen, wir würden doch mal gerne diese Daten haben, weil wir sind die Musikindustrie und die Bevölkerung schädigt uns oder aber andere Geschichten. Und ich glaube da ist im Moment auf allen Seiten der Topf ganz schön am Kochen.
Ich meine, okay, davon abgesehen, was passiert für den User, was passiert für uns, was ändert sich für uns, das ist die Frage.
Ja, du wirst wie gesagt mit Faustkeil und Stiefeltafel schreiben dem nicht. Telefon haben wir gerade geklärt. Frank hat ja gerade das Stichwort E-Mail angegeben. Vielleicht können wir das Stichwort E-Mail angeführt. Vielleicht können wir noch mal ein bisschen genauer darauf eingehen, was jetzt bei den E-Mails da speziell passiert.
Ich denke bei der E-Mail werden wir auch noch ein bisschen ausholen müssen, wie jetzt eigentlich ein E-Mail genau technisch funktioniert. Das ist ja für viele Leute auch nicht so ganz 100 Prozent klar. Also klar, man klickt den Sendenknopf und der andere drückt auf Abrufen. Aber was da genau technisch auf dem Weg passiert, ist schon ganz wichtig, um auch zu verstehen, wo jetzt diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich einsetzt. Sind aber eigentlich eure Fragen jetzt erst mal so weit geklärt, also was den Abruf angeht oder?
Ich hätte eigentlich noch eine Frage in Bezug auf das Telefonieren.
Patrick?
Und zwar ist es nicht eigentlich relativ unwahrscheinlich oder relativ wahrscheinlich, also so wahrscheinlich besser formuliert, dass dann, dass es trotzdem die Möglichkeit besteht und das auch durchaus schon gemacht wird, dass Inhalte mitgeschnitten werden oder die irgendwie halt registriert werden, weil im Internet kursieren doch unter anderem auch schon welche Programme, die man sich halt ganz einfach runterladen kann, mit denen man dann ja irgendwie keine Ahnung Inhalte lesen kann und sein das Handy von irgendeinem Freund oder der Freundin irgendwie sowas verfolgen kann, oder?
Also rein vom Technischen ist es natürlich möglich und auch nicht erst seit 2008 oder 2007 Telefongespräche mitzuschneiden und möglicherweise auch eine Spracherkennung dazu machen. Also das ist bei den Geheimdiensten, die machen das schon. Das sind natürlich ziemlich komplexe Systeme.
Na ja, vielleicht können wir bei dem polizeilichen Bereich da auch kurz reden. Deutschland ist jetzt auch nicht nur relativ also in Bezug auf die Bevölkerung, sondern auch absolut Weltmeister im Überwachen der Telefone, also der Gespräche. Wir haben so derzeit Zahlen von 35.000 abgehörten Gesprächen von also im polizeilichen Bereich. Das sind aber dann nur die Anschlüsse. Das heißt, man muss mit den Personen multiplizieren, die betroffen sind. Dann kommt man schon weiter auf über 100.000 Betroffene. Also wir sind weltweit die Nation, die am meisten Telefone abhört im polizeilichen Bereich. Ja, das ist aber unabhängig, genau. Also das ist unabhängig von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also wirklich nochmal ganz klar, es geht nicht um die Inhalte, um die Kommunikationsinhalte. Manchmal lässt es nicht so ohne weiteres trennen, das sehen wir gleich bei E-Mail. Aber in der Regel, also beim Telefon, es geht jetzt nicht, also es wird jetzt nicht dieses Gespräch, es wird zwar mitgeschnitten, ihr habt jetzt bei Fritz angerufen am Mittwochabend, aber es wird jetzt nicht mitgeschnitten, was wir jetzt hier sprechen.
Genau, also da würde jetzt zum Beispiel drinstehen, dass Thorsten im Blumen bei Fritz angerufen hat und seit zwölf Minuten dieses Gespräch dauert.
Dann haben wir deine Ortstaten gar nicht.
Na doch, der Anschluss hat ja einen Ort.
Na, wenn ihr den seht, dann ja, ich glaube, wir sehen den nicht.
Nee, wir sehen den nicht.
Weil der ist unterdrückt.
Ach, warte mal, ganz kurz, zwei Klicks.
Nee, ich seh dir das raus. Was?
Ob ihr meine Nummer, ihr seht meine Nummer nicht.
Nein, wir sehen deine Nummer nicht.
Genau.
Wenn du jetzt hier einen Terroranschlag ankündigen würdest, dann könnte es aber sicher sein, dass die Nummer dann bei den Behörden landet.
Ah ja, also bei Bedarf schon ermittelbar.
Aber nicht von uns, sondern eben von einem Telefonanbieter.
Bei der Gelegenheit nochmal eine andere Sache erwähnen, die jetzt hier so ein bisschen mit reinkam. Natürlich verflechtet die Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht nur die Verbindungsdaten bei den Anbietern zu speichern, sondern auch die Bestandsdaten. Was heißt das? Die Bestandsdaten sind in der Regel also die Nutzer, die man den Nutzer zuordnet. Die Kundendaten. Dazu kommt noch die Zahlungsart, Kontoverbindung, die Art der TK-Dienste, die Rufnummer. Das sind natürlich Daten, die dazukommen und die auch in Deutschland am allerhäufigsten abgerufen werden. Nein, ich meine es ist schon von den Ermittlungsbehörden. Also dass eben diese Bestandsdaten dazukommen, das wird immer viel vergessen.
Also es steht eben nicht nur, dass deine Nummer die andere Nummer angerufen hat, sondern ich kann zu der Nummer, die dann da steht, nicht ich, aber die Behörden, könnte sich der Nummer auch noch abrufen, aha, das ist Thorsten aus Berlin und der ist so und so und so. Ich würde sagen, damit ist das Stichwort Telefon jetzt erstmal im Groben beendet.
Genau, wir werden da später nochmal drüber sprechen.
Ich komme später nochmal drüber. Eure Fragen klären wir gleich auch noch dazu. Aber wir kommen jetzt glaube ich erstmal zum spannenden Thema E-Mail, weil da brauchen wir ein paar Minuten. Thorsten ist deine Frage damit erstmal erklärt.
Ja, wunderbar.
Großartig. Patrick, du auch?
Ja, danke.
Super, dann viel Spaß noch, schönen Abend und bis dann. So, eure Fragen zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die ja seit einem Monat läuft, die uns alle auch betrifft, unter der 0331 70 97 110. Wie das im Speziellen bei Telefon funktioniert, haben wir gerade geklärt. Frank, wie ist es jetzt bei E-Mails?
Bei E-Mails ist es so, wenn ihr, was ja wahrscheinlich die Vielzahl von euch ist, keinen eigenen E-Mails Server habt, das lassen wir jetzt mal raus, das ist mal ein ganz spezieller Fall, aber ihr habt irgendwo einen E-Mail Account, sagen wir mal, bei web.de, gmx, yahoo.com, Google Mail. Richtig, denn werdet ihr entweder über einen Web-Interface, also über einen Browser, eure E-Mails schreiben oder ihr habt euer E-Mail Programm so eingerichtet, dass ihr da irgendwie den Account eingetragen habt. Das heißt also, wenn sich erst mal euer E-Mail, also ihr schreibt die E-Mail, dann sagen wir mal, ihr habt ein Modem, wählt euch ein, kein DSL, sondern angenommen, ihr habt ein Modem. Um die E-Mail abzuschicken, dann wählt ihr euch bei eurem Internetprovider ein, dann kriegt ihr eine IP-Adresse. So, dann ist erst mal so ein Verbindungsdatensatz erzeugt. Das heißt, User XY hat zu dem Zeitpunkt die und die IP-Adresse bekommen. Das heißt also, über diese IP-Adresse bei der Einwahl seid ihr also erst mal da registriert. So und dann drückt ihr auf den Senden-Knopf und dann verschickt euer E-Mail-Programm die E-Mail erst mal natürlich an den Server von eurem E-Mail-Anbieter gmxweb.de, was auch immer. Und dieser Anbieter muss dann erst mal auch diesen Vorgang registrieren. Das heißt also, er hat dann eure E-Mail-Adresse, er hat natürlich also eure Kundendaten, mit denen ihr euch angemeldet habt und er muss auch die Zieladresse registrieren. So und dann schickt er die weiter, wenn ihr jetzt nicht gerade zu einem anderen Benutzer von dem gleichen Anbieter geht, sondern zum Beispiel schickt es zu irgendeiner Uni ist ein blödes Beispiel.
Ich schick das von GMX zu Yahoo.
Genau von GMX zu Yahoo. Dann baut der Mail-Server von GMX baut dann wieder eine Verbindung auf zu Yahoo. Bei Yahoo kommt dann wieder eine Verbindung von GMX von dem User, der wir hier eine E-Mail einliefern, an den User. Das heißt also da wird es auch wieder gespeichert und dann speichert das Yahoo in eurem E-Mail-Postfach. Und dann im E-Mail-Postfach wird dann entweder von einem anderen Benutzer auch wieder über ein Webinterface abgerufen oder auch von einem E-Mail-Programm. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das bei Yahoo geht, aber sagen wir mal, es geht. Bei Yahoo wird es dann auch wieder abgerufen. Das heißt also da ist dann der E-Mail-Programm. Das verbindet sich dann über das IMAP-Protokoll oder POP3-Protokoll. Das sind also die gängigen Mail-Abrufprotokolle, verbinden sich dann mit dem E-Mail-Server von Yahoo. Und da wird dann auch entsprechend auch wieder registriert. Aha, da wurde jetzt irgendwie eine Mail abgerufen und sozusagen Mail von da nach da wurde bewegt.
Und damit sind die Daten sowohl vom Absender als auch vom Empfänger da.
Richtig, genau. Und wenn ihr mal wissen wollt, wie das genau aussieht, das kann man nämlich auch selbst alles nachvollziehen. Da braucht man also gar keine Behörden zu. In eurem E-Mail-Programm gibt es in der Regel die Funktion vollständigen Header anzeigen oder Kopfzeilen anzeigen oder sowas. Da seht ihr genau den kompletten Weg, den die Mail gegangen ist, weil das die E-Mail-Server unterwegs mit protokollieren. Das heißt also jeder Server, die diese Mail gesehen hat, schreibt eine Zeile rein und sagt hier, ich war dabei. Und so kann man ziemlich genau nachvollziehen, wann, welchen Weg die Mail gegangen ist. Und auch manchmal ganz interessant, wenn es ein bisschen länger gedauert hat, kann man mal sehen, wo es eigentlich liegen geblieben ist.
Und jetzt ist interessant, du hast gesagt, welcher Server hat diese Mail gesehen? Sehen die auch, was in der Mail drin steht?
Die Server sehen natürlich auch erstmal, was in der Mail drin steht. Und bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung für E-Mails fängt es dann auch interessant zu werden, weil sich diese Zeilen nicht so ohne weiteres ganz doll trennen lassen. Also bei einem Telefonat ist das relativ klar. Da gibt es einen Verbindungsdatensatz. Da wird ja auch eine Rechnung geschrieben dafür. Aber die Gespräche sind eigentlich technisch getrennt. Also man spricht da von einer eigentlich auch Out-of-Band-Signalisierung, sagen die Fachleute. Das heißt also die Vermittlungsdaten, die Verbindungsdaten sind technisch von den Sprachdaten getrennt oder von den Inhaltsdaten. Und bei einer E-Mail ist es aber alles mittendrin. Es ist also dann, wenn ihr euch, da gibt es auch die Funktion Quelltext, dann E-Mail anzeigen oder Kopfzeichen. Ihr seht, oben zwar sind Hatter, das ist so ein Stück mit vielen kryptischen Zahlen drin. Und dann die E-Mail, aber das ist tatsächlich eine Datei. Also das ist ein Stück E-Mail.
Weil der Server das nicht trennt.
Weil der Server das nicht trennt. Das heißt also, wenn man diese Verbindungsdaten irgendwie mitspeichern will, muss man zwangsläufig irgendwie diese Mail angucken.
Na da kommt sogar noch ein kleiner Aspekt dazu, denn man hat ja üblicherweise Subject, also die Betreffzeile. Die enthält ja oft auch schon irgendwie Angaben zum Inhalt der Mail. Viele Leute neigen ja dazu, den Inhalt der Mail zusammenzufassen.
Also wenn ich dir eine Mail schicke und sage, die Mail heißt Chaosradio 131, und dann schreibe ich Konstanze, wie sieht es aus? Kommt ihr pünktlich? Geht es euch gut? Seid ihr gesund? Alles klar. Dann weiß der Server, der zwischen deiner und meinem E-Mail-Programm steht, schon, ach, die hacken doch schon wieder irgendwas aus. Es geht wahrscheinlich um die Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung. So grob zusammengefasst wäre das. Wenn der Heder aber heißen würde, Schokoladenpudding mit Erdbeereis. Oder Vanillesoße. Und dann sind sie erst recht gestimmt, neugierig, weil es ist ja Chaosradio. Okay, führt zu weit, aber wir haben das Prinzip begriffen.
Genau.
Jetzt hab ich wieder den Ball weit aus dem Feld rausgeschossen, oder? Macht ja nichts. Wir waren dabei, die Verbindungsdaten zwischen zwei Leuten, die sich eine Mail schicken, werden gespeichert. Ich habe die Stammdaten dieser Leute, weil die haben sich ja bei einem Mail-Programm, bei einem Mail-Provider angemeldet. Die kann ich also abrufen und da die Mail von einem Server zum anderen geht und überdurch in ihren Server durch, ist auch der Inhalt der Mail eigentlich nachvollziehbar.
Und die IP und die tatsächliche Mail-Adresse sind ja sozusagen die wichtigen Daten. Die Nummer, die IP eben, die tatsächliche Mail-Adresse.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt denke, ich bin total clever und schicke die Mail nicht als Jakob Kranz-Ad, sondern als irgendwie Schnufti-Bufti, dann kann ich denken, ich bin total super, weil ich habe die Aussiedrigst, aber das ist den Behörden ja egal.
Genau. Was auch ein weit verbreiteter Irrtum ist, dass wenn man über das Web-Interface reingeht, sich möglicherweise ein Fantasienamen ausdenkt, irgendwie so ein Fantasie-Account einrichtet, dann werden in den E-Mails aber in der Regel doch auch die IP-Adressen übertragen und mitgespeichert von dem Browser, von dem ich das gemacht habe. Also auch bei einer E-Mail, die mal eingeliefert wird, ist es wichtig zu wissen, dass dann tatsächlich auch die IP-Adresse dann bekannt gegeben wird. Also da haben sich schon ein paar Leute, die es eigentlich besser wissen müssen, haben sich da auch schon ganz schön nass gemacht. Irgendwie einer war unser guter Freund Kim, Kim Schmitz, der denn aus einem Hotel in Thailand, einem Journalisten in Deutschland, eine E-Mail geschickt hat und dann war es ja ziemlich schnell klar, wo es herkommt, weil man an der IP-Adresse gesehen hat, hat in dem Hotel alles klar, keine Fragen.
Jetzt können wir natürlich dazu, was kann man tun, damit einen das nicht trifft. Das ist ja auch Thema der heutigen Sendung. Stichwort E-Mails verschlüsseln. Bringt das überhaupt was? Dann ist zwar der Inhalt der E-Mail verschlüsselt, aber die Verbindungsdaten sind trotzdem da. Was kann man ansonsten noch tun? Wie geht ihr mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung um? Darüber würden wir mit euch gerne reden. 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben noch eine Mail bekommen von Tanja. Die würde gerne wissen, wie die Daten von Handy, Internet und so weiter und so fort zusammengeführt und vernetzt werden, unter welchem Namen die gespeichert werden. Das klären wir alles nach den Nachrichten. Also holt euch kurz eine kalte Brause. Wir machen danach weiter. Spannendes Thema Chaosradio 131. Ein Monat Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Na herzlichen Glückwunsch. Freie Musik, neue Musik, Creative Commons Lizenz drunter. Also können wir spielen, könnt ihr euch saugen. Ernesto heißt der Mann, Terror Alarm das Stück, gehört im Chaos Radio Teil 131 auf Fritz. Wir reden über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die läuft seit einem Monat. Wie geht ihr damit um und was können wir tun, damit die Daten möglichst schwierig von den Behörden zu kriegen sind? 0331 70 97 110, gleich geht's weiter.
Das ist ratzfatz ausverkauft und prompt ist es ausverkauft. Tja, da kann man nix machen. Außer vielleicht zum Zusatzkonzert gehen?
Fritz präsentiert Wir sind Helden.
Das Zusatzkonzert in Potsdam.
Wir sind Helden.
Jetzt auch Sonntag, 13. April in der Schinkelhalle Potsdam.
Mehr Infos.
Fritz.de Das Zusatzkonzert in Potsdam.
Und wir sind übrigens immer noch Fritz.
Und das hört man 22.33 Fritz Info Nachrichten Mit Liane Gruß Der seit zehn Monaten andauernde Tarifstreit zwischen der Bahn und den Lokführern ist zu Ende. Das haben beide Seiten am Abend in Berlin bestätigt. Der lange umkämpfte, eigenständige Tarifvertrag soll am 1. März in Kraft treten und zehn Monate gelten. Die Lokführer bekommen damit Gehaltserhöhungen von 11 Prozent und eine Einmalzahlung von 800 Euro. Außerdem gilt ab Februar 2009 die 40-Stunden-Woche. Bahnchef Medorn und GDL-Chef Shell wollen den Vertrag in der nächsten Woche unterschreiben. Der Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft der Polizei Freiberg hat eine Bestandsaufnahme aller privaten Waffen gefordert. Er bezeichnete es als Skandal, dass man zwar wisse, wie viele Bananen nach Deutschland eingeführt werden, aber nicht bekannt sei, wie viele Waffen es gibt. Im gleichen Zuge begrüßte er das Vorhaben der Großen Koalition, künftig alle anscheinens Waffen, attrappen, die echten Waffen nachempfunden sind, zu verbieten. Aber man sollte diese Waffen nicht nur verbieten, man müsste auch Bußgelder verhängen. Zwischen den Koalitionsparteien in Brandenburg ist ein Streit um einen landesweiten Mindestlohn entbrannt. Hintergrund ist der Vorschlag der SPD, öffentliche Aufträge nur noch von Unternehmen an Unternehmen zu vergeben, die einen Mindestlohn von 7, 50 Euro zahlen. Dem RBB-Politikmagazin Klartext sagte Finanzminister Speer, die SPD-Versuche gegenwärtig die CDU davon zu überzeugen. Die Mensa des Jahres steht in Würzburg. Die meisten Studierenden haben sich bei der Wahl des Hochschulmagazins Unicum für die Würzburger Unikantine Bursa entschieden. Insgesamt machten mehr als 33.000 Studenten mit. Auf den Plätzen 2 und 3 der Gesamtwertungen folgen Mensen in Bremen und Karlsruhe. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. Kortbus und Frankfurt 3 Grad, Potsdam, Neuropin, Wittenberge und Angermünde 4 Grad und in Berlin sind es auch 4 Grad. Heute Abend gibt es viele Wolken, es kann immer wieder Regen geben bei Tiefstwerten bis minus 2 Grad. Morgen ist es erst freundlich, später dann gibt es wieder mehr Wolken und besonders zum Abend kann es auch wieder regnen bei Höchstwerten bis 6 Grad. Auf den Straßen ist alles okay, gute Fahrt.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2 dann fritz rund um Spremberg.
Herzlich willkommen zum Blue Moon auf Fritz 0331 70 97 1 1 0 ist unsere Nummer. Hier ist der Chaos Computer Club. Immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat gibt es bei Fritz das Chaos Radio zu Gastin Constanze Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir reden über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die seit 1. Januar, also seit vier Wochen, uns alle erfreut und beglückt.
Und da wir gerade bei der Mensa in Würzburg waren, haben wir hier auch noch was von unseren Kollegen in München, die suchen nämlich ganz, ganz dringend einen Raum für ihren CCC, da wo sie sich treffen können. Ich weiß, das ist ja Berlin Brandenburg, aber wir wissen ja auch, dass ihr auch von ganz woanders hin hört, dazu hört. Und deswegen wollen wir hier mal ganz kurz in Aufruf starten. Wenn ihr eine Idee habt für einen coolen Clubraum, keine Ahnung, so vielleicht 50 Quadratmeter, 100 Quadratmeter oder so was, kann ruhig ein bisschen reccy sein, ein bisschen coole Gegend sein. Dann schickt am besten mal eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir leiten es dann weiter.
Wir müssen da vielleicht ein paar Sachen betonen, dass die Münchner Nerds und CCC-Mitglieder einfach die tollsten Mieter sind, die man sich vorstellen kann und dass man einfach total gerne eine Gruppe Hacker bei sich her als Untermieter hat.
Und sie haben keine Haustiere.
Hier ist die, ich muss ja ein bisschen mehr Taumbrünnigkeit überlegen. Hier ist die kleine Immobilien-Show bei Fritz, wenn sie auch hier was haben. Nein, Blödsinn, ja. Okay, also ich hoffe ihr könnt den Münchner CCC-Leuten helfen, wenn nicht gibt es heute Abend kein Abendbrot. Tanja hat ja eine Mail geschrieben, die wollte wissen, wie werden denn die Daten von Handy, Internet etc. miteinander vernetzt und zusammengeführt.
Ja, diese Zusammenführung ist eine ganz interessante Sache. Das ist nämlich auch der Knackpunkt an der ganzen Geschichte. Also eigentlich wären die Daten fast nur halb so harmlos, nicht halb so gefährlich, wenn sie für sich allein stehen würden. Die polizeiliche Ermittlungsarbeit läuft aber hauptsächlich über die Zusammenführung von Daten. Das heißt also Netze bilden, darstellen, Zusammenhänge herstellen, zeitliche Zusammenhänge, Personenzusammenhänge. Das ist also das, warum man diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung vor allem haben will. Es geht also wirklich nicht um die alleinstehenden Daten. Also im Prinzip interessiert es keinen. Aber klassisches Beispiel von den Drogenfahndern ist jetzt, da kriegt jetzt ein Dealer irgendwie den Anruf von irgendjemand. Das ist ein bisschen mehr als die übliche Menge. Und dann fängt er an loszutelefonieren bei seinen Großhändlern und will dann wissen, wo er irgendwie den besten Preis kriegt für die Menge. Das ist so eine klassische Geschichte. Das heißt, man hat also diesen zeitlichen Zusammenhang. Irgendwie Konsument ruft Dealer an, Dealer ruft Großdealer an. Und man kann dann damit anhand des zeitlichen Zusammenhangs ziemlich guten Bild machen, wie diese Geschäftsbeziehungen dann sind. Das ist so ein klassisches Beispiel. Genau. Das gleiche natürlich bei vermeintlichen Terroristen. Wobei da ist es glaube ich eher so ein Traum, ein Wunschdenken, dass man damit am besten noch Anschläge sogar im Voraus verhindern kann. Aber es geht ja auch darum, in die Vergangenheit zurückzublicken. Es gibt mehrere Softwareprodukte dafür, wo man einen Riesenberg Verbindungsdaten reinwirft. Dann eine Person raussucht oder anwählt und kriegt dann eben dieses Netz. Also das ist wirklich wie so ein Netz, muss man sich das vorstellen, mit so verschiedenen Grafen, Zeigern zu den verschiedenen Akteuren. Man kann sich eine Zeitleiste darstellen. Das ist mittlerweile ganz gut umgesetzt und macht eigentlich auch ziemlich viel Spaß, in so was rumzuklicken. Es gibt da auch, glaube ich auch von einigen Produkten, gibt es auch eine Demo-Software kostenlos mal zum runterladen, wer sich das anschauen will. Man muss natürlich schon ein bisschen mit Daten bestücken. Erst mal ein bisschen was reingeben, wonach man suchen will. Man kann jetzt nicht sagen, such mir mal irgendwie aus den Verbindungsdaten der Deutschen Telekom, such mir mal einfach alle Terroristen der letzten sechs Monate raus.
Wahrscheinlich wäre das aber ein frommer Wunsch von einigen Da und Herren.
Ja, manche Leute denken sich vielleicht auch so, dass es so einfach ist. Nee, man muss also schon ein bisschen einen Startpunkt geben und kann sich dann aber ganz gut durchhangeln und ja, also denke mal, dass die Daten geben wirklich auch ziemlich viel her. Es ist ein sehr mächtiges Werkzeug.
Ja, das praktische an dieser ganzen Maßnahme der Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder die jetzt im europäischen Rahmen mehr Data Retention heißt, ist auch die technische Harmonisierung. Das heißt, dass die Standards, wie in welcher Weise eben diese Daten gespeichert werden, angeglichen werden. Das wird natürlich den Ermittlungsbehörden diese Auswertung viel leichter machen können.
Wir haben ja unter anderem heute auch das Subthema, sagt man wohl in Neudeutsch, also das eigentliche Unterthema auch dieser Sendung Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist da. Was kann man denn dagegen tun? Wir haben eben schon kurz erwähnt, wie das mit den Handys läuft, welche Daten da gespeichert werden, weil wenn man irgendwas dagegen tun will, muss man ja erstmal verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert. Dann hat Frank gerade eine sehr schöne Kurzzusammenfassung gemacht, wie eigentlich E-Mail funktioniert und was die Server, die zwischen unseren beiden E-Mail-Programmen stehen, was die alles mitlesen. Was ist denn jetzt, wenn ich meine Mails verschlüsseln? Dann kann niemand den Inhalt der Mail lesen, aber die Daten sind trotzdem, quasi die Verbindungsdaten werden ja trotzdem gespeichert. Bin ich damit nicht umso verdächtiger, weil ich was zu verbergen hätte?
Also wir wollen ganz kurz noch ein bisschen mehr ins Detail gehen. Verschlüsselung ist nicht gleich Verschlüsselung, sondern es gibt die sogenannte Transportweg Verschlüsselung. Das kennt ihr aus oder wahrscheinlich. Ich fürchte, ihr kennt es nicht, aber ihr seht es in eurem E-Mail Programm, wenn ihr euch mal ein bisschen durch die Optionen durchwählt. Das gibt denn da in der Regel so ein Hekchen SSL oder TLS Transport Layer Security benutzen. Das könnt ihr mal ausprobieren. Vielleicht funktioniert es sogar bei eurem Diensteanbieter. Das heißt dann, dass der Transportweg von eurem E-Mail Programm zu dem nächsten Server zumindest erst mal gesichert ist. Das hat den Vorteil, dass wenn zum Beispiel, wenn ihr das in einem WLAN macht, dass denn da niemand mitlesen kann, was ja schon mal ganz gut ist, wenn ihr irgendwo in der Öffentlichkeit seid, irgendwann am Flughafen oder so. Das ist also schon mal ein erster Schritt. Hat aber jetzt erst mal mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich auch nichts zu tun. Genau.
Verschlüsselung von Mails hilft nicht gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Die Transportverschlüsselung hilft erst mal nur gegen neugierige Lauscher in der Regel, was aber ja auch schon mal immer was ist. Und dann gibt es die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung. Klassisches Beispiel dafür wäre PGP oder GPG, also GNU-PG, wo dann also die gesamte Mail verschlüsselt wird und erst vom Empfänger wieder verschlüsselt wird.
Ja, aber das ist nicht wirklich Ende zu Ende. Das heißt also End to End heißt natürlich dann, dass der Verschlüsselungsweg von einem zum anderen Empfänger verschlüsselt ist. Also bei PGP ist natürlich im Prinzip so, dass nur der Empfänger die Mail wieder entschlüsseln kann und niemand zwischendurch, aber das würde man nicht jetzt End to End bezeichnen. End to End ist der Weg und nicht der Inhalt.
Also der Inhalt, ja. Genau, also der Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung für die Inhalt der Mail, aber natürlich eben nicht für die Mail, weil tatsächlich die Mail wird nach wie vor auf dem herkömmlichen Weg transportiert, also von meinem E-Mail Programm zum Server, zum nächsten Server, zum nächsten Server und dann zum Empfänger. Und dabei fallen natürlich diese Verbindungsdaten auch wieder an.
Gut, also fassen wir kurz zusammen. Man kann zwar seine Mails verschlüsseln, es hilft aber nicht gegen die Vorwärtsdatenspeicherung, die Daten laufen trotzdem auf. Und bevor wir jetzt zum Thema Internet kommen, was nochmal weitert fällt, nehmen wir mal ein paar Leute ran, die sich schon die Ohren wundtelefoniert haben. Ganze Menge. Wir versuchen mal die Leiste abzuarbeiten. Der erste am Telefon ist Falco aus Berlin. Guten Abend Falco. Grüße dich herzlich. Was ist dein Begehr?
Ja, und zwar folgendes, also die Konstante meint der Fund schon, von wegen, es werden keine Inhalte in dem Sinne gespeichert, was ja auch soweit richtig ist.
Bei welchem, du bist beim Handy gerade oder wo?
Ich bin eigentlich generell überall.
Handy, Festnetz, E-Mail. Und zwar, also es sieht ja im Grunde so aus, wenn man mal darüber nachdenkt, wo man überall anrufen kann, jetzt zum Beispiel bei einer Suchtberatungsstelle, bei einer Familienseelsorgestelle oder man kann nicht eigentlich alles Mögliche denken. Da kann man ja eigentlich schon alleine auf den Verbindungsdaten vielleicht mehr Rückschlüsse auf die Probleme ziehen, weshalb man da irgendwie anruft.
Selbstverständlich, konstruieren wir mal die Situation, du willst dich irgendwo bewerben, in irgendeinem Beruf, wo deine Gesundheit wichtig ist und du hast nebenbei noch einen Termin bei deinem Physiotherapeuten, weil du Probleme im Kreuz hast, was auch immer und dann hast du noch mit deiner Krankenkasse telefoniert und so weiter und sofort, wenn man aus diesen Daten ein Netz baut, könnte man schon mal sagen, Falko, sag mal, was hast du eigentlich für ein gesundheitliches Problem?
Richtig und ich finde, das ist was ziemlich wichtiges, also was auch oft übersehen wird, es wird immer groß von der Politik gerade gesagt, ja, es werden keine Daten gespeichert, also keine Inhaltsdaten, aber im Endeffekt lässt sich alleine schon aus den Verbindungsdaten, die gespeichert werden, eine Menge Rückschlüsse darauf ziehen, worum es sich letztendlich handelt.
Ja, exakt, das ist immer so eine politische Behauptung und Frau Zypries hat ja auch in keinem Interview vergessen zu betonen, dass es eben nur die Verbindungsdaten seien. Aber da hast du eigentlich echt schon zum Knackpunkt angesprochen, denn am Ende ist es ja so technisch auswertbar. Es ist natürlich viel einfacher, wenn man diese Verbindungsdaten hat, packt man halt in seine Software, fallen einem die gewünschten Daten schon raus. Gegenüber den Inhalten dieser Gespräche, da ist es natürlich viel schwieriger, die auszuwerten, viel langwieriger und bei den Verbindungsdaten ist es halt super einfach und praktisch. Und wenn auch die Bestandsdaten dazu kommen, also dann mit den Adressen, mit den Kontoverbindungen.
Also deine persönlichen Daten mit Adresse, Umnahme und so.
Genau und dazu noch eben das geografische Profil im Falle von Handys. Ich meine, das ist perfekt für Ermittler. Trotzdem ist es so, dass es eigentlich im gesamten Bereich von Europa keine Studien gibt, die bisher beweisen, dass diese Verbindungsdaten tatsächlich für die Ermittler viel bringen. Das heißt, trotz der vielen Behauptungen konnten eigentlich noch in gar keinem europäischen Land diese Studien vorgelegt werden.
Geschweige denn irgendwie Terroranschläge im Vorfeld verhindern.
Na dann sowieso nicht.
Holger ist jetzt am Telefon, der hat auch eine klasse Frage. Falko, ich glaube, wir haben das Thema jetzt nur kurz angerissen.
Das war sehr wichtig, denke ich.
Sehr wichtig für den Anruf und alle, die zugehört haben, denken bitte mal drüber nach, wenn sie sagen, mir egal, ich hab noch nichts zu verbergen. Kein Problem. Holger hat einen Einwurf, den ich großartig finde. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob wir ihn beantworten können. Nament Holger.
Hallo.
Sahran.
Erstmal ein schöner Gruß in die Runde.
Danke, zurück. Danke.
Ich find's klasse, dass ihr diese Sendung macht. Ich würde sagen, ich bin selber technologischer Analfabet und aus dem Grunde ist mir allerdings auch klar, dass mit jedem Stück Technik, was man sich in die Wohnung holt, sozusagen auch immer ein Stück hat, was man nicht kontrollieren kann, richtig. Und mein Problem ist jetzt, ich wollte mein Handy wegschmeißen. Die Sache ist, ich hab zum Beispiel letztens vom Kumpel gehört, dass es wohl auch die Möglichkeit gibt, über den Lautsprecher dich abzuhören, wenn das Handy ausgeschaltet ist. Weil es jetzt nicht obdurch stimmt.
Das ist glaube ich ein bisschen James Bond mäßig, oder?
Also, frag mal weiter erstmal.
Okay, gut. Also das war jetzt nur ein Fragezeichen. Ist mir im Prinzip auch egal. Hab ich nur gehört.
Weil du es schon weggeworfen hast?
Nee, nee, nee. Ich hab's nicht weggeworfen im metaphorischen Sinne sozusagen. Nee, was ich meine ist eigentlich, dass sich ja auch irgendwie die Benutzungsbedingungen dann ändern. Und ob ich dann nicht aus meinem Vertrag, weil die sind ja immer sehr langfristig.
Ach so, du meinst, dass du hast einen Mobilvertrag mit Firma XY und jetzt gibt es die Vorratdaten-Speicherung und die sagen, Holger, deine Daten werden ab sofort sechs Monate gespeichert.
Ich hab da noch nicht mal was bekommen.
Ja, ja, warte mal. Und damit könntest du jetzt wiederum sagen, ich versuch das nur mal kurz zu formulieren, damit könntest du jetzt sagen, liebe Firma XY, damit verstoßt ihr gegen den Vertrag, den wir beide mit nah haben und ich würde gerne kündigen. Das ist eine geile Idee.
Also vielleicht eine kleine Anekdote am Rande. Es gab tatsächlich auch mal ein Internetprovider, der gesagt hat, so liebe Kunden, wir müssen jetzt speichern, wir haben ganz erhebliche Kosten und deswegen müssen wir jetzt leider das mit fünf Euro pro Monat auf eure Gebühren umgehen.
Toll.
Naja, die Idee ist leider zum Scheitern verurteilt, weil ja die Anbieter gesetzlich verpflichtet sind und da hast du leider kein Ausstiegsrecht aus dem Vertrag. Also es gibt so ein paar Zahlen dazu, die mitkommen, also der Verband der Kommunikationsunternehmen und Informationsunternehmen, ich weiß gar nicht wofür die Abkürzung steht, Bundesverband, Frank weiß das doch sicher. Egal. Jedenfalls haben die mal eine Zahl genannt, was eigentlich das insgesamt kosten würde, die technische Umsetzung und sie haben davon um dreistellige Millionenbetrag gesprochen. Klar, dass sie irgendwie diese Daten an die Kunden umlegen. Also dass jetzt wie bei dem eben von dem Beispiel von Frank gleich explizit gesagt wird, so wir haben jetzt Vorzeitsprechung, bitte zahlen sie 8, 70 Euro mehr, so wird es wohl nicht sein. Aber dennoch, klar, werden wir die Kosten.
Die Kosten sind enorm.
Aber du wirst deinen Vertrag da nicht kündigen können. Im Zweifelsfall müsstest du dann mit deinem Anbieter direkt mal ein persönliches Gespräch führen.
Wobei natürlich, aber andererseits, also der Einwirt oder die Frage ist nicht so ganz unberechtigt, weil theoretisch müssten die Anbieter ja wirklich auch ihre Vertragsbedingungen entsprechend anpassen. Das heißt also mich zumindestens darüber informieren, dass es so ist.
Sie werden dann sagen, auf unserer Webseite sind die neuen ADWs einsehbar.
Aber die müssen die ja schon zuschicken.
Das steht irgendwo auf deiner Rechnung in so einer Punkt-Sechserschrift.
Also Moment mal, das müssen wir schon auseinanderhalten. Die Telekommunikationsanbieter dürfen diese Daten nicht selbst nutzen. Sie speichern für fremde Zwecke. Aus Datenschutzgründen dürfen sie die auch nicht verwenden, wie etwa in anderen Ländern ist, wo ja zum Beispiel die Verwerbung weiterverwendet werden muss. Entsprechend müssen sie nicht ihre RGB ändern. Sie tun das ja fremdbestimmt.
Ah, okay, da ist der Haken, alles klar. Also du siehst, Holger, kommen wir nicht weiter auf dem Acker.
Tut uns leid.
Lass dich so stehen, schönen Abend noch. Wir waren ja bei Telefon, wir waren auch bei E-Mail, was wir gerade erklärt haben, wie das mit SSL und PGP-Verschlüsselung funktioniert. Und an dem Moment hakt der Andre ein, der jetzt am Telefon ist. Guten Abend, Andre. Mach mal bitte dein Radio leiser, am besten aus. Und in der Zwischenzeit, wenn du es ausmachst, versuche ich zu erklären, worum es dir geht. Wenn wir nämlich schon über E-Mail-Kommunikation reden, sind wir ganz schnell bei ICQ, Messenger, Chatprogramm etc. PP. Wie ist das?
Trifft es das? Ja, unter anderem. Also, ich wollte eigentlich wissen, ob das die Inhalte oder generell auch Verbindungen, also mit wem ich mich unterhalte, sag ich jetzt mal, ob die das auch speichern oder abhören können.
Also abhören, ja, prinzipiell ja. Ja klar, seit du triffst irgendwelche Vorsichtsmaßnahmen wie Verschlüsselungen oder so was. Was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung angeht, sind diese ganzen Instant-Messenger-Geschichten eine interessante Frage.
Also sie sind enthalten bei, wenn man sich anguckt, wie die technischen Chantisierungen aussehen, und zwar sind sie enthalten mit der NIC, also der Account Name, mit dem man sich einloggt und die IP. Aber da wir wieder mal ein Problem haben, dass die konkrete technische Umsetzung ja noch fehlt für die Dienstanbieter, können wir es noch nicht genau sagen.
Und die Frage ist natürlich auch, wie sowas definiert ist. Also ein Instant-Messenger ist ja nicht gleich ein Instant-Messenger und ein Chat ist nicht gleich ein Chat. Deswegen ist das also eine ganz, ganz große Frage und wird zumindest dieses Jahr glaube ich nicht mehr geklärt werden. Beziehungsweise, das sind ja auch gerade Protokolle, die jetzt nicht so fest eingefahren sind wie E-Mail oder Webklicken. Also HTTP, also Internetseiten abrufen. Sondern das sind Protokolle, die eigentlich noch relativ jung sind. Also zum Beispiel Java als eins oder das sind teilweise Firmen, proprietäre Protokolle, also eigene Firmen, eigene Protokolle. Da ist es gar nicht so einfach. Und die können die natürlich auch nach Belieben ändern, weil dann spielen die halt den Leuten neue Software. Also wenn jetzt drin steht zum Beispiel die und die Verbindungen auf Port 1835, die irgendwie so und so mit dem und dem Zeichen anfangen. Das sind jetzt irgendwie Chatverbindungen und die müssen jetzt mal mitprotokolliert werden, sagt der. Gut, dann gehen wir halt irgendwie auf Port 5728 und fangen unsere Nachrichten mit irgendwie ABC.
Damit ich es mal wieder von vorne anfange.
Genau, dann fangen wir von vorne an. Also ganz so einfach ist es dabei nicht. Bei Voice over IP, ist es ein bisschen ähnliches Problem. Also bei Internettelefonie, weil es da ja auch neben dem De facto Standard SIP gibt es ja auch noch firmeneigene Protokolle, firmeneigene Varianten Skype zum Beispiel. Und da wird es ja schon richtig hakelig, sowas so technisch festzunageln, dass man dann auch wirklich die Provider verpflichten kann, das dann durchzuführen.
Also ist, um das jetzt mal kurz runter zu distillieren, die Kommunikation per ICQ oder Chat in dem Fall doch ein bisschen cleverer als per Mail, beziehungsweise Voice over IP cleverer als telefonieren, da dort die technischen Umsetzungen und die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen noch nicht so genau festgenagelt sind.
Naja, man muss sich schon noch mal darüber am klaren sein, dass seine IP-Adresse bei der Einwahl ja auch mal schon registriert ist.
Also ich würde sagen nicht. Das ist eigentlich vom Überwachungslevel her ähnlich.
Sie können das weder abhören noch lesen.
Naja, aber sobald du online bist, haben sie deine IP.
Aber nur die Verbindung dann.
Also was vielleicht auch noch ein wichtiger Punkt ist, dass natürlich immer Anbieter, also kommerzielle Anbieter, vor allem Großanbieter, immer ein leichtes Fressen oder ein potentielles leichtes Beuteopfer sind für Ermittlungsbehörden, die also dahingehen können sagen, wir haben ja irgendwie Nutzer und der hat, ob es jetzt stimmt oder nicht, keine Ahnung, mit Kinderpornografie gehandelt oder ein Terroranschlag geplant ist, kann ja der Anbieter gar nicht nachprüfen. Der darf ja nicht in die Nachrichten reingucken. Das heißt, die können ihm erstmal prinzipiell alles erzählen. Also ist es zum Beispiel bei der Operation Mikado passiert, da ging es also darum, wo also Kreditkartenabrechnungen durchleuchtet worden sind, wo man also den Firmen gesagt hat, also jetzt war ganz ganz böse und ihr müsst jetzt mal bitte mitmachen. Im Zweifelsfall kann man da also auch ziemlich viel Druck auf den Anbieter von so einem Chatdienst, von so einem Messengerdienst ausüben, dass der auch entsprechend dann den Nick oder vielleicht auch irgendwie die letzte IP-Adresse, wo die Kommunikation stattgefunden hat, rausrücken kann.
Also da muss man sich vielleicht auch nochmal folgende klar machen. Das gilt eigentlich für fast alle europäischen Länder. Die Abhörschnittstellen, das ist also nicht nur die Verbindungsdaten, sondern das sich auch die Inhalte betrifft, die sind ohnehin bei uns gesetzlich verpflichtend. Das heißt, die Schnittstellen, um technisch eine Abhörmaßnahme zu ermöglichen, müssen diese Anbieter haben. Insofern ist da nur noch die Frage, wie die gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen aussehen und wer unter welchen Umständen, mit welchen Schranken darauf zugreifen kann. Technisch müssen die gegeben sein.
Wie ist jetzt der Stand der Dinge mit der Klage vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht, die ja mehrere Leute angestrebt haben. Vorratssatenspeicherung, die immer noch nicht durch ist. Warte mal, Andrej, ich hoffe deine Frage ist damit beantwortet.
Ja, ich hatte aber noch eine zweite.
Okay, danach kommen wir zum Verfassungsgericht.
Es gibt ja halt so eine Programme, die generell die Internetverbindung verschlüsseln, also JAP, also Java in und aus.
Ja, verschlüsseltes Internet machen wir in wenigen Minuten. Okay, sonst behopsten wir hier von einem Thema zum nächsten, es wird dann ein bisschen chaotisch. Aber habe ich auf dem Zettel, machen wir. Ja, aber Chaos fetzt ja nur, wenn man trotzdem weiss, wo die Reise hin geht. Verstehst du? Genau. So, deswegen machen wir jetzt Musik. Nein, machen wir nicht. Tschüss André. Die Frage nach den Klagen kommt nämlich unter anderem auch von Max. Hallo Max.
Hallo.
Schönen guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ehe ich wieder Sachen formuliere, die du gar nicht so meinst, sag mal selber.
Also meine Frage war, es gab ja bevor der Vorratsdatensprechunggesetz beschlossen wurde und zwar noch nicht eingeführt wurde, wurde ja schon vorbereitet von der bekannten Seite. Mir fällt gerade da nämlich ein so eine Massenklage.
Das ist der AK Vorratsdatensprechung, also der Arbeitskampf.
Jedenfalls wollte ich bloß wissen, weil ich habe davon lange nichts mehr gehört.
Wie der Stand der Dinge ist. Ja genau, einfach.
Naja, man kann das zusammenfassen als ein unglaublich großer Erfolg. Der CTC gehört ja quasi zu der Unterstützergruppe vom AK Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Es sind weit über 30.000 Briefe eingegangen. Also es gibt über 30.000 Kläger bei diesem Berliner Anwalt, die vor das Verfassungsgericht gezogen sind. Das ist doch viel mehr als erwartet. Klickt haben noch viel mehr, um mit zu unterstützen. Es war jetzt am Ende so, dass ja unmittelbar nach, also nach Beginn des Januars dann nochmal so ein Eilantrag gestellt wurde, um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gleich auszusetzen. Aber hier kam es zu einem Kompetenztreit in Karlsruhe. Denn es gibt ja zwei Senate bei Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und hier haben sich quasi beide Senate darum gerissen, diese Entscheidung zu treffen. Weil es gibt ja zwei Probleme. Eben einmal die Fragen des Datenschutzes und ja, also die ganze Problematik der Überwachung will ich es mal nennen. Aber zum anderen gibt es natürlich auch europarechtliche Fragen. Denn es gibt ja die EU-Richtlinie, die die Grundlage dieser Vorratssatenspeicherung ist. Und also da konnten sich jetzt fast einen ganzen Monat lang diese beiden Senate nicht einigen.
Ich glaube es waren sogar drei, ne? Also die Strafprozessuale Sache war also noch mal ein Teil Aspekte.
Ja genau, es gibt dann sehr viele Aspekte.
Also es sieht nicht so aus, als ob es da nächste Woche eine Entscheidung gibt.
Ja doch, sie haben sich heute geeinigt. Genau. Es ist jetzt also klar, wo das und wie, von welchen Leuten es verhandelt wird, von welchem Senat, Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und ja, das ist zumindest erst mal ein erster Schritt.
Es ist schon sehr wichtig, denn sicherlich ist es mehr als nur so eine Nebenfrage, aber dass es so lange gedauert hat und das ist der 6. Ausschuss in Karlsruhe.
Also ein Vermittlungsausschuss oder so.
Genau, wenn so eine Art Vermittlungsausschuss tagen muss, war schon erstaunlich. Und sie haben quasi jetzt die verschiedenen Klagen, denn es gibt noch mehr Klagen, ein bisschen getrennt und die Aspekte aufgeteilt. Also beide Senate sind jetzt zuständig.
Wobei man auch noch mal sagen muss, also das ist zwar sehr lobenswert, dass 30.000 Leute da jetzt quasi eine Klage vor der Macht gegeben haben, aber die Zahl ist letztendlich für das Gericht nicht entscheidend. Also es ist für das Gericht kein Unterschied.
Ich bin auch einer von denen, das ist wohl wichtig, denn es ist schließlich die größte Verfassungsklage aller Zeiten.
Ja, aber für die Entscheidung darf es natürlich nicht entscheidend sein, ob jetzt 3 Leute oder 30.000.
Jetzt mach doch mal sein Mikro aus.
Soll das ja Spielverderber werden.
Max, pass auf.
Aber es ist natürlich großartig, dass so viele Leute dabei waren und letztendlich auch der Erfolg der Demo im September gezeigt. Also das ist einfach ein Thema. Also wir sind jetzt hier nicht irgendwie Außenseiter und ihr, die ihr jetzt hier anruft und euch Sorgen macht, ihr seid keine Außenseite. Es ist voll Mainstream und Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist scheiße und wir dürfen jetzt auch ruhig alle dagegen sein.
So, und wie gesagt, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich jetzt geeinigt, wer darüber bekakelt und wir wollen mal hoffen, wie es ausgeht.
Ich hab jetzt darauf gehört, dass die Anzahl ja nicht wichtig ist der Person, die sich da gemeldet haben.
Also es ist natürlich schon der Impact, also 30.000, das ist halt das erste Mal, dass es in der Größenordnung, dass sie einfach so viele Leute den Arsch hochbekriegt haben und dann gesagt haben, okay, wir sind jetzt total dagegen. Ich denke, es wird auch schon ein bisschen ein Eindruck hängen bleiben bei den Richtern. Aber natürlich von einer sachlichen Entscheidung dürfte es eigentlich keinen Unterschied machen, ob eine einzelne Person oder 30.000 geklagt haben.
Es ist natürlich schon auch so, dass man sich ein juristisches Bild machen kann. Es ist ja so, dass die Juristen jetzt seit Monaten über die Verfassungsmäßigkeit dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung streiten. Wenn man da Lust hat auf juristische Zeitung und sich da mal durchliest, dann ist einem sehr schnell klar, dass es jedoch sehr, sehr viele Spannungsfelder gibt und dass vermutlich diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht Bestand haben wird. Da hoffen wir natürlich auch alle drauf.
Let's keep the fingers crossed, Zeig in dem Moment.
Die andere Sache ist natürlich noch auf der EU-Ebene. Das heißt, Deutschland hat sich dies ja nicht allein ausgedacht, sondern es ist eine Sache, die in der EU beschlossen wurde. Und die Frage ist, oder eigentlich ist es schon fast relativ sicher, dass es eben nicht so ist. Das heißt also, dass das Gremium gar nicht in der Lage war, so eine Verordnung zu erlassen. Das heißt also, das ganze Ding ist im Prinzip formal, wahrscheinlich hinfällig, mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit. Und dann steht Deutschland natürlich ziemlich blöd da, weil sie haben eine EU-Richtlinie in nationales Recht umgesetzt, die es dann plötzlich gar nicht mehr gibt. Das heißt also, eigentlich stehen die Abgeordneten, die dafür gestimmt haben, als ziemliche Trottel da, weil Deutschland hat voraus einen Gehorsam bewiesen und dabei ziemlich tief ins Klo gegriffen. Und zwar sozusagen.
Wir bleiben hoffnungsvoll gespannt, Max, stimmt's? Alle klar. Wenn Leute Sie zu mir sagen, fühle ich mich immer so komisch. Ich sag Tschüss Max, du sagst Tschüss Frank, Tschüss Konstanze, Tschüss Jakob.
Jetzt hast du noch meinen Namen vergessen. Na schon gut, leg mal einfach auf.
Chaosradio 131, 23 Uhr. Halbzeit, Bergfest. Naja, ich finde wir waren für die erste Stunde sehr, wie sagt man, stringent? Wir sind ordentlich durchgerauscht. Wir haben Wahlcomputer erklärt, wir haben erklärt, wie es mit Handys und Telefonen funktioniert. Bei der Vorwärtssadenspeicherung, Frank hat erklärt, wie das bei E-Mails funktioniert, wie E-Mails Verschlüsselung funktioniert mit PGP und SSL. Wir haben abgehandelt, wie es sich beläuft bei ICQs und bei Messengers und bei Chatprogrammen. Und jetzt kommt natürlich das große Thema, was ein bisschen mehr Zeit braucht, deswegen vorher alles ein bisschen komprimiert. Internet, wir müssen natürlich reden über Programme wie Tor, wir müssen reden über Programme wie JAP. Sind die Internetverbindungen jetzt dann sicher, wenn man es verschlüsselt oder nicht? All diese Geschichten zum Thema Vorwärtssadenspeicherung könnt ihr mit uns hier gerne besprechen im Blumenau Fritz unter der 0331 70 97 110.
Ich will noch eine Sache nochmal ganz kurz loswerden. Also nicht, dass ihr jetzt glaubt, wir sagen jetzt, ihr sollt eure E-Mails nicht mehr verschlüsseln. Nein, macht es natürlich weiterhin, auch wenn es jetzt nichts mit der Vorwärtssadenspeicherung zu tun hat. Verschlüsselt um Gottes Willen eure E-Mails, wie ihr das bisher hoffentlich gemacht habt. Besorgt euch ein Verschlüsselungsprogramm, installiert es, gibt es als Plug-in für euer Lieblings E-Mail Programm. Verschlüsselt eure E-Mails.
Ich glaube der Alphanord Markus Richter hat mehrfach über Verschlüsselungsprogramme für E-Mails referiert. Das kann man auf fritz.de nachlesen. Einfach mal klicken unter Games Multimedia. Spaß am Gerät heißt das. Guckt mal unter dem E-Mail Verschlüsselungsprogramm findet ihr auf jeden Fall irgendwas. Und wir, jetzt kommt jetzt, wir spielen eine Musik. Ich weiß wir reden ganz viel, aber ich würde ja eine Musik spielen. Heute eigentlich wollte ich nur von einer Platte was spielen, aber weil ich das sehe, spielen wir nur einen einzigen Song, weil wir reden ja so viel. Großartige Band kommt aus Schweden. Sänger kommt aus Detroit. Alte 60er-Soul-Legende, wieder ausgegraben worden von den Herren aus Schweden, heißen The Solution. Zweites Album kommt Ende Februar, wird heißen The Solution Will Not Be Televised. Bitte alle Spaß haben. B-R-L-I-C-K-U-N-E The Solution will not be televised kommt Ende Februar. Highjack and Love haben wir gehört. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Chaos Radio Teil 131. Wir reden darüber ein Monat Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Hurra, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Jetzt haben wir sie. Wie geht es euch eigentlich damit und was kann man tun, um es den Behörden möglichst schwer zu machen an die Daten ranzukommen, die sie eigentlich sammeln wollen. Und vorhin hatten wir ganz kurz den Einwand, dass es so das Gerücht rumgeht, dass man Leute über ein Handy abhören kann, über den Lautsprecher, wenn das Handy auch ausgeschaltet ist. Gehaltwissen. Frank, was sagst du?
Das geht in Richtung Bundestrojaner und Online-Durchsuchung. In dem Zusammenhang kommt es immer wieder diese Geschichte. Das ist also dieser Zugriff auf informationstechnische Systeme, wie es sich das Bundeskriminalamt und unser Innenminister wünschen. Das beinhaltet auch, dass man zum Beispiel Mobiltelefone, Handys ein bisschen manipuliert. Das heißt, eine kleine Software raufspielt und ein kleines Zusatzprogramm raufspielt, womit man dieses Handy dann in ein Abhörgerät verwandeln kann. Das heißt also, man legt das dann wohin.
Man kann es vielleicht mal allgemeiner sagen. Man muss jetzt mal konkret sich überlegen, ein Handy ist ein Computer und selbstverständlich kann man auch auf solche Handys, Spionage-Software aufbringen und dann etwa in so einem Modus fahren, dass es so tut, als wenn es aus wäre.
Also ein Telefon hat Software drauf und man kann auch zusätzlich Software installieren. Entweder wird halt die Vorhandene komplett ausgetauscht gegen eine manipulierte oder es wird eine zusätzliche aufgespielt.
Das bedeutet aber, dass du erstmal mein Telefon brauchst, um da Dinge mitzumachen. Also du kannst nicht in einer S-Bahn neben mir sitzen und mir irgendwas schicken, was ich nicht mitkriege.
So sollte es eigentlich nicht sein, aber es ist natürlich schon die Möglichkeit, moderne Handys haben sogenanntes Over-the-Air-Update, heißt das eine Funktion, wo also dann später auch mal die Netzbetreiber die Telefone einfach so updaten können, weil warum auch immer sie das machen wollen, wenn Software Updates, ja genau, aber wenn sozusagen der Netzbetreiber irgendwie ein neues Feature, eine neue Funktion auf das Telefon bringen will, was ein Software Update erfordert, dann können die das machen.
Du hast ja neulich diese SMS gekriegt, wo du so ja geklickt hast.
Das war die mit der Gehaltserhöhung.
Auf jeden Fall kurzum, also das ist keine komplette Urban Legend oder keine Spinnerei, es gibt tatsächlich so eine Software, die kann man auch kaufen. Ich sage jetzt nicht den Namen, weil muss ja nicht sein. Das ist auch nicht so toll die Software. Allerdings gibt es auch so ein paar Nebenwirkungen. Das geht jetzt nicht so ganz einfach. Das heißt, wenn man denn Gespräche aufbaut, die tauchen natürlich dann auch auf der Telefonrechnung auf. Man merkt, wie der Akku leer wird. Also es gibt schon Anzeichen dafür. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es komplett unbemerkt stattfindet. Und man muss irgendwie diese Software auch raufkriegen. Wenn ich jetzt gerade nicht Netzbetreiber bin, sondern irgendwie der eigentlich versüchtige Freund oder Freundin und mal wissen will, was mein Liebster oder mein Liebster da so tut, dann kann ich mir natürlich dieses Telefon schnappen. Aber dazu muss ich es eigentlich schon erstmal in die Hand bekommen.
Und wenn ich nicht möchte, dass sowas passiert, nehme ich einfach ein Akku raus.
Das ist eine Variante und hofft, dass nicht irgendjemand heimlich noch einen kleinen extra Akku wieder ins Telefon reingeschmuggelt hat. Aber das ist dann, also wie gesagt, der Paranoia Faktor kann da schon beliebig hoch werden. Aber also bei dringenden richtigen Besprechungen ist es schon so, dass die Handy am besten draußen bleiben.
Okay und damit sind wir jetzt im Blue Moon beim Thema Vorrats, Taschen und Ladensprecherungen, Internetverbindungen. Ich wähle mich in das Internet ein. Damit hatten wir vorhin schon mal Kriegner IP, also eine Nummer, die sozusagen meinem Anschluss zugeordnet ist von meinem Internet Provider, Firma Internet Dönikis, dann sagen kann, der Kranz war gestern Abend um 22.37 Uhr online, um zu gucken, wann der Bus fährt, weil er war bei rfbvg.de.
Genau und ganz wichtige Information zu wissen ist, dass bei den meisten Webseiten, also bei den meisten Servern, wird diese IP-Adresse auch gespeichert beim Zugriff. Das heißt also jeder Seitenabruf wird mit dieser IP-Adresse protokolliert. Das ist zwar eigentlich nicht legal, da gab es auch schon viel gezeter drum. Zum Beispiel haben Bundesbehörden speichern das auch. Da gab es dann auch ein Gerichtsverfahren, dass sie das jetzt nicht mehr speichern dürfen. Ich würde mal darauf wetten, dass die sich da einen Scheißdreck drum stören und scheren und es trotzdem weitermachen. Also bis auf die eine, die wir jetzt abgeschaltet haben, aber die anderen werden halt sagen, ja so what. Es gibt ja den jährlichen Big Brother Awards, also einen negativen Datenschutzpreis für die größten Datenkragen. Und da hat auch mal der in der Open Source Szene, glaube ich mit fast 50 Prozent Marktanteil, so einer der beliebtesten Web Server, der Apache Web Server hat auch mal einen Preis gekriegt, den Community Preis, also Kategorie Community, weil es einfach da standardmäßig eingeschaltet ist, dieses IP-Adressen mitloggen. Das heißt also, das ist eigentlich eine Sache, die nicht so toll ist, aber es ist standardmäßig da und eigentlich macht sich auch kaum jemand Gedanken. Die Leute finden es auch ganz interessant, die wollen mal wissen, wer kommt eigentlich so, woher kommen die Leute. Es ist so ein bisschen so diese Neugier, so wie das, ich würde am liebsten gerne irgendwie eine Webcam irgendwie beim Nachbarn durchs Fenster richten und mal schauen, was der dann so im Wohnzimmer treibt.
Das heißt, das ist der Punkt, an dem natürlich die Leute, die sich sehr dafür interessieren, also Musikindustrie, Filmindustrie, wo die dann sagen können, die üblichen Musik Download Portale, wie sie alle heißen, wer war da online, schickt mir noch mal bitte die IP-Daten, dann kann man nachprüfen, wer dann da drauf war und dann kriegt ihr Post oder auch nicht.
Genau, oder wie zum Beispiel ich mit dem Bundeskriminalamt und setze mal eine Seite auf, die ganz interessant ist. Ups, das Studio fällt auseinander. Ich hoffe, es war nichts Wichtiges.
Naja, jedenfalls hat man sich überlegen muss dabei ist natürlich, dass diese Forderungen schon offiziell gemacht wurden. Also etwa gibt es die schriftlich vom Bundesrat, der es gerne wollte und vor wenigen Tagen hat sich tatsächlich unser Kulturstaatsminister, der Herr Neumann, offiziell dazu geäußert und gesagt, ja, diese Daten müsste man der Content der Musikindustrie dann mal zur Verfügung stellen.
Genau, vielleicht noch ganz kurz, also BKA, die haben folgendes gemacht, die haben eine Webseite aufgesetzt. Da ging es irgendwie, es war eine Informationsseite zur militanten Gruppe. Also man behauptet eine terroristische Vereinigung, es ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung. Und man hat also einfach die IP-Adressen von den Leuten mitprotokolliert, die diese Seite besucht haben, haben gedacht, naja, wenn Sie sich dafür interessieren, dann sind es doch mal hier unsere potenziellen Verdächtigen. Und haben dann quasi mittels der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sie hieß noch nicht so, aber es ist natürlich so, auch dass die Internet-Provider die IP-Adressen auch bisher schon gespeichert haben, eine Weile, noch nicht so lange. Aber die meisten haben das verbotenerweise, meistens verbotenerweise trotzdem gemacht. Dann ist man zu denen gegangen und sagt, okay, wir essen das jetzt hier und haben den Leuten mal eine Hausdurchsuchung gemacht. Weil es war ja schon verdächtig genug, dass die da auf der Webseite waren und sich dafür interessiert haben.
Soviel zum Prinzip, was da alles funktioniert, wie sowas mitgeloggt werden kann. Wie habe ich als Privatperson eine Chance, diese Spuren zu verschleiern, zu verschlüsseln? Damit sind wir bei Dingen, die wir ansprechen wollten, wie Tor, wie JAP, also Verschlüsselungsprogramme.
Also Tor ist halt eine gute Möglichkeit.
Was ist Tor?
Tor ist der sogenannte Tor-Onion-Router, also das ist die Abkürzung dafür quasi und es hat eine sehr populäre Methode. Also eine der gängigsten in Deutschland. Es gibt noch ein anderes Projekt, nämlich JAP, also ein Konkurrenzprojekt quasi. Man kann ja mehrere Methoden verwenden und hiermit kann man sich also effektiv dieser Vorratsdatenspeicherung entziehen.
Was machen diese Programme?
Also Tor, Tor-Onion-Router, also Zwiebel kommt also von diesem Zwiebelschalen.
Das ist schön, da hat man die schöne kleine Zwiebel unten im Browser.
Und die Idee ist, dass also wie bei diesen Zwiebelschalen, also viele Schichten hintereinander, ist also so, dass die Kommunikationsdaten da von einem Server zum nächsten verschleiert werden.
Es wird also keine direkte Verbindung mehr zwischen dem Kunden, also mir als Server und dem Server mehr hergestellt.
Das heißt der Server weiß nicht mehr, dass du dich da einloggst, sondern die Anfrage kommt von irgendwo aus Papua originär.
Genau und es gibt irgendwie, jetzt muss ich kurz zu Konstanzen rüber gucken, ich glaube drei oder fünf sind immer in so einer Kette. Man kann es glaube ich auch einstellen.
Unterschiedlich, ja man kann es teilweise auch einstellen. Es gibt einige Software, die man sozusagen nicht dazu installieren kann bei dem Betriebssystem, wo man auch sehen kann, auch grafisch teilweise jetzt schon, wo die Route langgeht. Also es werden quasi andere Server ausgesucht, über die dann geroutet wird.
Diese Server oder diese Tor-Server in dem Sinne sind es ja nicht. Es sind ja Vermittlungsstellen oder Weiterleitungsrechner. Die sollten natürlich möglichst gut verteilt sein. Diese Server werden, dieser Dienst wird von, ja in der Regel Organisationen, teilweise Privatpersonen bereitgestellt, die es wichtig ist, dass da Privatsphäre beim Internet-Surfen gewahrt wird. Der Chaos Computer Club zum Beispiel betreibt sowas. Aber auch, ja, Filbo oder angeschlossene Organisationen in den USA, gibt es viele Organisationen, also die stehen schon in einigen Ländern, weil es einfach schon genug Leute gibt, die auch den Nutzen von diesen Dingern erkannt haben. Ein Beispiel ist auch mal, wenn man jetzt Zensurbestrebungen in einem Land umgehen, oder Zensurmaßnahmen, Stichwort China, dann ist also so ein Dienst natürlich Gold wert.
Und innerhalb also dieser Schichten wird natürlich verschlüsselt, sodass auch im Nachhinein die Verbindung nicht rückwärts wieder aufgerollt werden kann.
Das klingt nach, wenn man über Vorratsdatenspeicherung redet, und wir hatten ja gerade bei Mails und so, gibt es nicht wirklich eine Chance. Das klingt jetzt nach der eierlegenden Wollmilchsau, die den einzigen Nachteil hat, dass die Internetverbindung ein bisschen langsamer wird, weil es ja über mehrere verschiedene Ecken geht und einfach länger unterwegs ist.
Ja, kann man wohl grundsätzlich so sagen. Natürlich muss man eine Unbequemlichkeit entkaufen, das ist nämlich genau die angesprochene Geschwindigkeit. Ich persönlich habe dafür eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit gefunden, da ich ohnehin im Browser immer recht viele Taps auf dem Hab, also es ist häufig halt immer mehrere Taps. Also mich persönlich stört es nicht so. Wenn man es jetzt erstmalig benutzt, wird man sicherlich sich wundern, wenn man sich so ein bisschen ins Modem-Zeitadter zurückversetzt fühlt. Und man hat manchmal Probleme, dadurch dass man die sogenannten Exit-Notes, also die Knoten, die aus dem Netzwerk herausführen, die kann man filtern und es gibt einige Seiten im Internet, die diese auch tatsächlich filtern. Also da gibt es manchmal schon Probleme, dann muss man halt manchmal seine Identität einmal wechseln. Das ist möglich mit der Software. Manchmal auch zwei, dreimal.
Funktioniert JAP genauso? Also ohne jetzt ins ganz tiefe technische Detail zu gehen, also TOR ist ganz einfach, nicht mehr der direkte Weg von mir zum Server, der dann nachvollziehbar ist, sondern es geht über drei oder vier Punkte.
In so einem Schalenprinzip.
Oder nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Billard und du weißt plötzlich nicht mehr, von welcher Bande kommt eigentlich die Kugel. So ähnlich funktioniert das?
Ja, insofern ist JAP natürlich vergleichbar. JAP ist ein Projekt der Uni Dresden. Und auch lange gefördert. Also hier in Deutschland, also mit öffentlichen Mitteln gefördert. Das ist ein ähnliches Prinzip. Natürlich, man muss überlegen.
Also steht auch im Telemedien, Teledienstegesetz steht, dass also auch eine anonyme oder eine pseudonyme Nutzung von Telediensten möglich sein muss. Und wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die IP-Adresse wirklich meiner Person dann auch zugeordnet ist, wenn vielleicht nicht für den Anbieter ersichtlich, aber insgesamt doch irgendwie eine Zuordnung möglich ist. Oder gerade wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel an der Uni ist, dann haben die Rechner in diesen Pools oftmals feste IP-Adressen. Das heißt also, man kann wirklich sehr gut feststellen oder in Büros, Mitarbeiterbüros, teilweise immer noch öffentliche IP-Adressen. Das heißt, sie sind dann auch wirklich einer Person zugeordnet.
Naja, das ist vielleicht auch mal eine Sache, die wir aber mal auch mal prinzipiell ansprechen sollen. Die Vorstellung, die viele Leute haben, ganz egal, was Frank jetzt meint, was natürlich richtig ist, die Vorstellung, dass man eine IP-Adresse erstmal prinzipiell einer Person zuordnen kann, ist natürlich nicht immer gegeben. Zunächst mal kann man damit, wenn man Glück hat, einen Rechner identifizieren. Nicht aber sehen, wer da wirklich sitzt.
Genau, weil du hast ein offenes WLAN, was ist sicherlich auch eine Kneipe, die hat ein offenes WLAN da. Und ich weiß zwar irgendwie, zu welcher Kneipe der Anschluss gehört, aber nicht ob jetzt Heinz, Peter oder Erwin da sitzen.
Oder es zeigt auf eine Note, also intern hängen da noch mehrere Rechner dran. All dies ist möglich, das ist oft so eine, das hört man von Politikern, die jetzt nun technisch ja meistens nicht so, die hören man halt auf das DIP.
Was war nochmal ein Browser?
Jaja genau, die Internetausdrucke.
Wobei es also schon so ist, dass diese Zuordnung natürlich erstmal gemacht wird. Das heißt also, wenn du ein offenes WLAN bei dir hast, dann bist du derjenige, der irgendwie morgens vom SEK aus dem Bett geklingelt wird.
Und du musst dann erklären, was da eigentlich los war. Okay, dann nachdem wir das jetzt so ein bisschen eingeordnet haben, seid ihr jetzt wieder dran? 0331 70 97 110. Michaela aus Münster ist am Telefon, die im weitesten Sinne eine Internetfrage hat. Hallo Michaela. Du hast bis jetzt nicht zu gestinkigt, weil du eine Weile warten musstest.
Ist nicht so schlecht.
Wir mussten das ja. Deine Frage bezieht sich auch aufs Internet, wird aber doch ziemlich speziell. Schieß mal los.
Ja genau, und zwar habe ich eine Spielekonsole seit über einem Jahr und darüber kam man auch ins Internet über Weißland. Und da habe ich, ja genau, ne, ja doch, das ist richtig. Ja ich wusste nicht ob man es sagen darf.
Es gibt noch Wo und Was und Wer und alles mögliche.
Gut, ne, auf jeden Fall bin ich damit ins Internet gegangen, über eine Suchmaschine auch. Und hab dann was bestimmtes eingegeben, weil ich was gesucht habe und auf einmal stand da mein eBay-Name, obwohl ich den noch nie da eingegeben hatte. Also da war ich auch total geschockt.
Ach so, warte mal, aber du hast...
Wo stand der in der Suchmaschine?
Ich hab es auch noch nicht so ganz verstanden, ehrlich gesagt.
Du hast dich bei eBay angemeldet und dein eBay-Name stand schon drin.
Nein, nein, also ich hab nur übers Internet, bei Google zum Beispiel, hab ich was eingegeben. Ich wollte eigentlich zu einem besonderen Markt, also DB-Markt heißt es ja, und dann zeigte mir Google auf einmal meinen eBay-Namen, aber auch den Markt, der da für zuständig ist. Also da, wo ich eigentlich gucken wollte. Aber da stand mein eBay-Namen drüber.
Das klingt ein bisschen komisch. Ich wüsste jetzt erstmal auf Anhieb nicht, wie das zustande kommt, ehrlich gesagt.
Im Zweifelsfall einen anderen eBay-Account anlegen.
Also ich mein, vielleicht hast du irgendeinen Bekannten, der einen eigenen E-Mail-Server betreibt oder jemand, der so quasi mal technisch so einrichten kann, dass du auf einem, also zu Hause, man kann ja auch auf seinem PC einen Web-Server relativ schnell einrichten, also zumindest unter Windows, wahrscheinlich Mac auch unter der Linux. Aber dass du dann mal mit dieser V auf die Webseite gehst und ihr dann mal gemeinsam in das Protokoll rein guckt, ob vielleicht diese Spielekonsole irgendwelche komischen Daten mitschickt.
Also ich würde das machen, da wäre ich jetzt schon neugierig. Ehrlich gesagt hat mir noch nie jemand so einen Fall erzählt. Also das würde ich echt gerne mal prüfen lassen. Kannst du uns ja dann mal in die Mail schicken und sagen, was rausgekommen ist.
Also wende dich vertrauensvoll an deinen zuständigen Alphanart.
Also können wir hier am Radio jetzt auch nicht klären.
Ja ist okay, gut, war nur eine Frage.
Aber spannende Geschichte, danke für den Einwand. Nächster am Telefon ist Tom aus Berlin. Hallo Tom, guten Abend.
Ja und zwar, ich hab zwei Fragen. Eins betrifft auch so was, was mit Google zu tun hat. Und zwar über Google hört man ja immer alles Mögliche, so von wegen was die mit den Daten so machen.
So was hört man denn da?
Überwiegend ungute Sachen, vor allem aus dem Ausland jetzt. China fällt mir da spontan ein, dass sie da massenweise Daten verkaufen. Und wenn man weiß, wie die Chinesen damit umgehen, dann ist es natürlich nicht so schön. Und meine Frage ist einfach, wenn ich jetzt bei Google zum Beispiel was eingebe, Suchbegriff, was auch immer, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass die, also dass sie es speichern, davon gehe ich ehrlich gesagt aus, aber wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass es auch weiterverwendet wird?
Von wem weiterverwendet? Von Google oder von Behörden möglicherweise?
Ja, im Prinzip egal. Also wäre Google dazu quasi in der Lage, das an Dritte entweder zu verkaufen, so Marketing-technisch, oder wären die dazu verpflichtet, sozusagen das an Behörde weiterzugeben?
Also wenn Tom, um den Fall zu konstruieren, weil wir sind ja immer noch bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wenn Tom bei Google eingebt, er interessiert sich für, wir sagen mal, Ledergeschirre für seinen Chihuahua-Pudel, ist dann Google unter anderem in der Lage, nicht nur zuzuordnen, dass sich da jeder, dass Tom sich sozusagen dafür interessiert und das auch noch weitergeht? Also ist Tom mit der Anfrage identifizierbar?
Bisschen handfester vielleicht noch, die Behörden gehen zu Google und sagen, der Tom war am Samstag von 14 bis 16 Uhr mit der IP-Adresse eingewählt und wir wollen jetzt mal wissen, was er in der Zeit alles bei Google nachgeguckt hat. Das ist technisch überhaupt kein Problem. Ob Google jetzt so die Daten so einfach rausrückt, weiß ich nicht. Es wird schon noch was vorliegen müssen, also zumindest eine Anordnung. Aber im Prinzip spricht dann nichts dagegen, dass Google, wenn sie diese Daten haben, die dann auch rausrücken muss.
Also klar muss einem natürlich dabei prinzipiell sein, dass Google keine Suchmaschine ist. Sollte einem immer klar sein, sondern dass Google ein großer Datensammler ist. Und vollkommen klar ist aber natürlich auch, dass Google also auf jeden Fall aufhebt, weil das ist der Zweck der Unternehmung, dass sie alles das, was gesucht wird, eben abspeichern.
Und dann noch...
Genau, da war eine zweite Frage.
Also, genau, und zwar Google Maps zum Beispiel. Wenn ich jetzt häufiger, ja, da Adressen suche und so weiter, dann ist Google natürlich auch daran interessiert, dass, also das irgendwie zu speichern, denke ich mal, um sich irgendwie mein Profil noch besser irgendwie anlegen zu können. Und wenn man jetzt, wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, dass Handy geortet wird und so weiter in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das würde dann quasi auch einfach weitergegeben werden, theoretisch.
Handyortung hat direkt nicht so viel mit, ist nur ein kleiner Bruchteil von Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau, genau, aber dass man quasi, lieber Google, du meinst Google Maps?
Oder meinst du jetzt Google Maps? Also es gibt ja auch jetzt die Funktion auf Mobiltelefon, dass ich mich da drüber orten lassen kann.
Das wäre jetzt quasi, das wäre als nächstes so, wenn man jetzt sich ein neues tolles Handy kauft, dann hat man ja mittlerweile auch ab und zu die Funktion, dass man da eingebautes Navi und so weiter hat. Ein guter Freund von mir, der benutzt das, der klemmt sich das dann immer auf sein Fahrrad vorne dran und fährt damit durch die Stadt. Wäre es quasi ohne Weiteres möglich, seine komplette Route durch ganz Berlin nachzuvollziehen, was er so am Tag macht und wo er hinfährt?
Also vielleicht ein kleines Missverständnis oder eine kleine Richtestellung zu GPS. Also GPS ist eine reine Einweggeschichte. Das heißt also GPS ist immer nur vom Satelliten zu uns runter. Wenn nicht das Gerät selbst irgendwelche Daten wieder wohin sendet, also das ist ein Einschränk. Aber rein GPS, also wenn ich jetzt einfach nur ein Navigationsgerät hab, ohne Handy drinnen oder irgendwelchen anderen Schnickschnack, was irgendwo hin telefoniert, dann ist GPS eine reine Einweggeschichte. Also nur anhand davon, dass ich ein GPS-Gerät hab, kann ich jetzt erstmal nicht geortet werden.
Genau, aber wenn ich jetzt mit dem Handy das quasi mache, dann muss ich auch erstmal die Anfrage schicken, nämlich die Adresse an den Satelliten schicken, der mir dann irgendwie sagt, wie ich da hinkomme oder so, oder?
Nee, du schickst es nicht, sondern der bekommt die Daten, die Positionsdaten. Allerdings ist es so, wenn das Handy eingeschaltet ist, dass es das gleiche wie auch bei der Lkw-Maut, bei diesen Onboard-Units, die in den Lkws drin sind, da ist einfach ein Handy drin. Alles, was ein Handy hat, ist auch ein Peilsender gleichzeitig. Also einfach immer technisch bedingt, muss ein Handy immer seine aktuelle Position an das Netz übermitteln, damit das Netz weiß, genau wo und welche Funkzelle. Also die aktuellen Mobilfunknetze sind ja so aufgebaut, dass man überall Masten hat. Je moderner die Netze, desto kleiner, engmaschiger ist dieses Netz, dass man kleinere Sendeleistungen braucht. Umso genauer muss das Netz auch wissen, wo das Telefon gerade angesprochen wird, wo es gerade erreicht wird.
Zu dem Thema würde ich gerne kurz einwerfen. Chaosradio.ccc.de Es gibt Podcasts zu den Sendungen, die auch in der Vergangenheit liefen. Unter anderem gab es eine großartige Sendung zum Thema wie funktioniert eigentlich das GPS-System bzw. wie funktioniert dieses Handy-System mit diesen ganzen Zellgeschichten.
Die Sendung war der GSM Podcast.
Genau. Kann man sich ziehen, anhören, Chaosradio.ccc.de und danach ist man schlauer. Ich sag's euch. Selbst ich hab's begriffen. Tschüss und grüß deinen Kumpel mit seinem komischen Navi auf der Fahrrad. Sag ihm, er soll mal über die Schulter gucken, bevor er bei Rot über die Ampel feuert. Tschüss. 0331 70 97 110. Das ist unsere Telefonnummer. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Teil 131. Wie immer am letzten Freitag im Monat. Zu Gast ist der Chaos Computer Club mit Konstanze, mit Frank. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sind gerade so ein bisschen abgeschweift in die Handy-Ortung und solche Geschichten, waren aber eigentlich dabei, wie sicher ist meine Internetverbindung? Da gab es einen schönen Einwand. Kann Google eigentlich irgendjemand weiter erzählen, was ich bei denen gesucht habe und was kann ich machen, wenn ich das nicht will?
Gerade da ist dann auch so ein Anonymisierungsdienst wie Tor dann wieder eine ganz wichtige Sache, weil mit Tor wird ja dann auch mal eine Identität gegenüber Google verschleiert. Das heißt also, die können dann nicht sehen, welche IP-Adresse das wirklich war mit der Anfrage, sondern es ist dann immer nur wieder die letzte sogenannte Exit-Note von diesem Tor-Dienst oder diesem Tor-Netzwerk, was denn in den Protokollen von Google oder dem anderen Web-Server auftaucht. So und deswegen ist es auch ganz sinnvoll, wenn man, wenn man zum Beispiel in einer Firma ist und mal ein bisschen recherchieren will und dann nicht sofort will, dass dann die Firmen-IP-Adresse bei den anderen im Protokoll auftaucht, dann ist das auch mal eine ganz sinnvolle Anwendung dafür. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt nur wirklich, wenn ich jetzt konkret was zu verbergen hab, wenn ich jetzt mal ganz klar und heimlich vielleicht auf irgendwelchen Schmuddelseiten rumsurfen will, sondern das ist eigentlich wirklich eine Sache, die im täglichen Einsatz ist. Und ja, je mehr Leute das auch gleichzeitig benutzen, desto mehr rauschen, desto mehr nutzlose Daten entstehen natürlich auch. Und dementsprechend wird es dann auch immer schwierig zu schauen, ob dann jetzt wirklich vielleicht jemand was zu verbergen hat. Das ist ja bei der Verschlüsselung immer so, wenn ich jetzt pro Tag 30 Mails schicke und davon nur eine verschlüsselte, dann liegt natürlich die Vermutung nahe, dass diese eine vielleicht ganz besonders wichtig war. Wenn ich jetzt aber von 30 Mails 28 verschlüsselte, dann ist es dann nicht mehr so einfach zu sagen, die war es jetzt.
Wie das genau funktioniert, wie Tor funktioniert, wie JAP funktioniert, wie Mailsverschlüsselung funktionieren, fritz.de klicken, Marcos suchen, Marcos Richter hat das alles online gestellt. Wir haben gleich die Nachrichten, danach müssen wir noch reden über Asterisk.
Genau, wie man Telefonie verschleiern kann.
Das müssen wir noch klären. Und vorher ganz kurz noch die Frage von Lutz aus Oranienburg. Ich hoffe, Sie ist einfach zu beantworten. Hallo Lutz. Guten Abend.
Guten Abend. Also meine Frage ist, also ich bin ja im Besitz eines eigenen Rott-Servers und wollte fragen, da ich über den per Remote-Desktop öfter mal im Internet surfe und auf Seiten chatte und E-Mails verschicke, also auf den Server und dann weiter.
Ist das sicher?
Auf dem Server selber einen Web-Server, also Web-Space-Server, also auch in Domainservern alles drauf hab. Ist der gegen Angriffe von außen, also gegen irgendwelche Spionageaktivitäten da geschützt oder muss ich da auch irgendwie den registrieren lassen, da ja auch dort E-Mails viele geschrieben werden, da ich ja auch viele E-Mail-Adressen dort vergeben hab.
Na, geht es dir jetzt darum, ob, ja, um die Verbindungsdaten oder geht es dir um irgendwie Spionagesoftware jetzt?
Beides, also...
Na, weil die Verbindungsdaten betrifft, kommt es natürlich erst mal zunächst darauf an, wie du dich, wie verbindest du dich remote zudem?
Per Windows, also über Remote Desktop, dann über die Benutzerdaten logon und dann wirklich drauf auf dem Desktop des Servers.
Ah ja, und du willst quasi wissen, ob die Leute, die deinen Webserver benutzen, ob da möglich ist, deren Verbindung zu kriegen, ja? Also man muss schon sagen, dass du natürlich jetzt kleiner anbieter, du würdest jetzt unter die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gar nicht fallen. Das heißt, bei dir sind in gewisser Weise Leute insofern sicher, dass du nicht für den Start die Verbindungsdaten halten musst für die Leute, die sich auf deinem Rechner einloggen.
Wobei vielleicht ein ganz kurzer Einwurf dazu. Es gibt nämlich eine ganz ganz großartige Alternative zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Der Fachbegriff dafür ist Quick Freeze. Also schnelles Einfrieren und meint, dass wenn tatsächlich ein konkreter Verdacht vorliegt, dass die Behörden dann zum Provider gehen, sagen, jetzt hätten wir gern für diese Kennung mal alle Informationen gespeichert. Sozusagen ab jetzt einfrieren, aufbewahren. Wir holen uns die vielleicht in zwei Wochen ab, wenn das Ganze konkret geworden ist. Und das ist eine Sache, die dich dann natürlich auch treffen könnte. Also wenn jetzt einer deiner Benutzer auf deinem Server da irgendwie verdächtigt wird, irgendwelchen Mist zu machen, dann kann die Polizei natürlich schon und die Behörden können dann schon zu dir kommen, sagen, wir wollen jetzt gern mal da die Daten von dem haben.
Also du bist damit nicht in einem rechtsfreien Raum.
Genau.
Und du bist dann auch verpflichtet, dem User das dann nicht mitzuteilen.
Zumindest wäre es nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Genau.
Ich wüsste, um ehrlich zu sein, oh ja nicht, wie ich die Daten da rauskriege, die da gespeichert werden.
Im Zweifelsfall wissen die Behörden schon, wie es da ist.
Im Zweifelsfall nehmen die einfach den Server mit und die wissen es dann schon.
Aber ich muss den jetzt nicht hier die Login-Daten für, dass sie da selber remote irgendwie so...
Dann nochmal ganz deutlich, sie nehmen einfach deinen Rechner mit, wenn du ihnen die Daten nicht lieferst.
Nee, der steht nicht bei mir zu Hause, der steht irgendwo in Deutschland im großen Server-Center.
Ja, ist ja noch einfacher.
Also beschlagnahmt wird oft genau dort.
Wir haben das Spielchen im letzten Jahr schon ein paar Mal durch, da ging es eben darum, dass einfach diese Tor-Server beschlagnahmt worden sind. Und da konnten wir ein breites Spektrum an Erfahrungen sammeln, sei es bei Privatpersonen, wo die Leute zu Hause standen, wo das gemietete Server waren, wo das irgendwelche Root-Server waren, die irgendwo bei einem Billighoster waren. Also da kennen die auch keinen Schmerz und das geht dann ratzfatz. Aber wie gesagt, wenn sowas ist, sowieso Anwalt und alles sein geordneten Gang gelassen.
Du bist als so ein kleiner Privater, vermutlich auch nicht kommerzieller Anbieter, jetzt nicht unter diese neue Gesetzgebung gefallen. Das betrifft jetzt erstmal, ich glaube die Zahl war 1000.
Wobei 1000, also ist es auch noch nicht ganz klar, da warten wir jetzt auch noch mal auf eine Präzisierung. Also 1000 Kunden, 1000 Nutzer, das ist ja eine sehr variable Zahl. Also gerade wenn man jetzt sowas hat, wie ein Web-Server oder irgendwie einen kleinen Telefonievermittlungsdienst, weiß auch immer, was sind denn. Also wenn ich jetzt gar keine Kundenbeziehung habe, das ist ja klar, wenn ich jetzt von irgendwie 1500 Leuten im Monat 10 Euro bekomme, dann ist es klar, wie viele Kunden ich habe. Aber wenn ich jetzt eine Dienstleistung habe, wo jeder mal hingeht, mal vorbeischaut, dann ist es ja alles gar nicht so klar, wie viele Kunden da jetzt wirklich sind, ob ich da jetzt betroffen bin oder nicht.
Und wie das mit der Telefonie und der Verschlüsselung der Telefonie ist, das klären wir nach den Nachrichten.
Aufwenden auch, tschüss.
Die exklusiven Fritz-Radio-Konzerte gehen wieder, wieder weiter. Diesmal mit neuer Musik aus England. Fritz präsentiert Maximo Part. Kommen den Freitag, live in den Fritz-Studios und natürlich im Radio. Mehr Infos fritz.de Karten zum dabei sein gibt's nirgendwo. Außer im www.meinfritz.de Einfach suchen, finden und gewinnen. Und das hört man.
Vier nach halb zwölf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Liane Gruß.
Der seit zehn Monaten andauernde Tarifstreit zwischen der Bahn und den Lokführern ist zu Ende. Das haben beide Seiten am Abend in Berlin bestätigt. Der lange umkämpfte eigenständige Tarifvertrag soll am 1. März in Kraft treten und zehn Monate gelten. Die Lokführer bekommen damit Gehaltserhöhungen von 11 Prozent und eine Einmalzahlung von 800 Euro. Außerdem gilt ab Februar 2009 die 40-Stunden-Woche. Warnchef Medorn und GDL-Chef Shell wollen den Vertrag in der nächsten Woche unterschreiben. Der Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft der Polizei Freiberg hat eine Bestandsaufnahme aller privaten Waffen gefordert. Er bezeichnete es als Skandal, dass man zwar wisse, wie viele Bananen nach Deutschland eingeführt werden, aber nicht bekannt sei, wie viele Waffen es gibt. Im gleichen Zuge begrüßte er das Vorhaben der Großen Koalition künftig alle Anscheinwaffen, attrappen die echten Waffen nachempfunden sind, zu verbieten. Aber man sollte diese Waffen nicht nur verbieten, man müsste auch Bußgelder verhängen. Zwischen den Koalitionsparteien in Brandenburg ist ein Streit um einen landesweiten Mindestlohn entbrannt. Hintergrund ist der Vorschlag der SPD, öffentliche Aufträge nur noch an Unternehmen zu vergeben, die einen Mindestlohn von 7, 50 Euro zahlen. Dem RBB-Politikmagazin Klartext sagte Finanzminister Speer, die SPD versuche gegenwärtig die CDU davon zu überzeugen. Der Hamburger SV hat erstmals seit elf Jahren wieder das vierte Finale im DFB-Pokal erreicht. Die Hamburger siegten gegen Rot-Weiß-Essen 3 zu 0. Auch der VfB Stuttgart ist eine Runde weiter, nach einem 3 zu 2 Sieg gegen die zweite Mannschaft von Werder Bremen. Carl Zeiss Jena gewann gegen Arminia Bielefeld 2 zu 1 und erreichte damit ebenfalls das vierte Finale. Und auch der VfL Wolfsburg schaffte den Sprung in die nächste Runde. Er besiegte Schalke 04 nach Verlängerung und Elfmeterschießen mit 5 zu 3. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Kortbus und Frankfurt 3 Grad, Potsdam, Neuropin, Wittenberge und Angermünde 4 Grad und auch in Berlin 4 Grad. Heute Abend gibt es immer wieder Wolken und Regen bei Ties werden bis zu minus 2 Grad. Morgen ist es am Anfang freundlich mit ein bisschen Sonne. Später dann gibt es wieder mehr Wolken und zum Nachmittag auch Regen bei Höchstwerten bis 6 Grad. A11 Uckermark Richtung Berliner Ring. Zwischen Korinne und Werbelin sind beide Fahrtrichtungen gesperrt. Hier gibt es derzeit Bergungsarbeiten und die A19 Rostock Richtung Wittstockdosse. Zwischen Wagen und dem Dreieck Wittstockdosse, da fährt ein Schwertransport. Hier könnt ihr zu der Zeit nicht überholen, ansonsten sind die Straßen aber frei.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, Chaos Radio Zeit, Chaos Computer Club bei Fritz, Konstanze, Frank, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, grüße euch ganz herzlich. 0331 77 97 110. Wir reden über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die uns seit einem Monat ja betrifft, so wir alle in irgendeiner Form mit anderen Leuten kommunizieren und vor allen Dingen auch was man tun kann, damit man es sozusagen ein bisschen schwieriger macht, seine Daten zu verschlüsseln. Wir haben schon gesprochen über Mails, über Mailverschlüsselungen wie SSL oder PGP. Wir haben gesprochen über die Möglichkeiten wie das beim Handy funktioniert. Da gibt es nicht all zu viele. Und wir hatten eben gerade mit Java, Quatsch mit JAP und mit Tor zwei Möglichkeiten zumindest die Internetverbindung einigermaßen zu verwischen. Und jetzt kommen wir zu Asterisk. Das ist eine Möglichkeit Telefonie, also Voice-over-IP-Telefonate. Und jetzt muss Konstanzin mir aus der Patsche hin.
Eigentlich muss ich diese Sache unbedingt Frank überlassen, denn er hat da heroisch im Selbstexperiment verschiedene Studien durchgeführt. Wir haben natürlich im CCC diverse Asteriske und wir selber benutzen die auch beide, aber Frank hat da echt so ein sportliches Projekt.
Zum Anfang, was ist ein Asterisk?
Okay, also ich fang mal an. Es gibt die Möglichkeit per Internet telefonieren. Eine Möglichkeit davon ist Skype. Das ist wahrscheinlich die bekannteste. Eine andere, die vielleicht macht ihr es in einer Firma mit euren Telefonen schon, wenn es sehr fortschrittlich ist. Möglicherweise habt ihr aber auch schon einen Telefonanschluss, der voice over IP basiert ist. Manchmal habt ihr das schon ohne es überhaupt zu wissen. Das läuft über das sogenannte SIP, also S-I-P Protokoll, was sich da jetzt so weitestgehend durchgesetzt hat. Und es ist einfach, ja, man hat keine feste Telefonleitung mehr, sondern benutzt das Internet. Also ihr könnt ja auch irgendwie Musik hören, Radio hören über das Internet. Also kann man auch telefonieren über das Internet. So und das ist dann mach ich dann in der Regel entweder am PC mit einem Kopfhörer, Mikrofon oder ich hab auch ein ganz normales Telefon, was bei mir auf dem Tisch steht oder ich hab dann so eine Wanderbox, die also dann mein analog Telefon in Voice over IP Gespräche wandelt. Und das Besondere dabei ist, dass ich also anders bei einem Telefonanbieter, da kann ich es ja auch machen, es gibt auch Call by Call, aber das ist sozusagen jetzt nochmal ein Stückchen weiter getrieben bei Voice over IP, weil im Internet kann ich mich ja wirklich überall hin verbinden. Das heißt also, ich kann mir zum Beispiel einen Voice over IP Anbieter in der Schweiz suchen, bekomme dann von dem möglicherweise sogar eine Schweizer Nummer, eine Schweizer Festnitznummer zugeordnet und verbinde mich dann aber über das Internet mit dem. Das heißt also, ich kann irgendwelchen Leuten eine Nummer, eine Festnitznummer in der Schweiz geben und das Gespräch kommt dann aber bei mir an über das Internet und für die Verbindung über das Internet wird ja erstmal nicht bezahlt, sondern ist es dann einfach, wenn jemand aus der Schweiz anruft, in der Schweiz in Nürnberg ist es einfach auch ein nationales Gespräch, also einfach ein normales Fernengespräch, kein internationales Gespräch, spart also auch schon mal eine Menge Geld. Das interessante dabei ist, dass also wir kennen jetzt die technischen Details für die Umsetzung von Voice-over-IP noch nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Sache, wenn man das sehr intensiv betreibt, kann man damit die Behörden schon deutlich verwirren, denke ich mal. Man kann das Ganze, das ist jetzt keine Sache, die jetzt ein kommerzieller Provider anbietet, aber wer jetzt ein bisschen technisch versiert ist, kann sich da mit Freunden zusammentun. Wir als Club haben das auch, so eine Infrastruktur. Ich persönlich hab das mal, um es einfach mal auszuprobieren, wie weit kann man das treiben, dass man sich also mehrere Voice-over-IP-Anbieter sucht, vielleicht noch einen eigenen Server betreibt. Man kann das auch über so dynamisches DNS zu Hause auch mal machen, dass man also selbst zu Hause einen eigenen Server hat und dann die Gespräche wild hin und her routen. Das heißt also, man kann sagen, viele Leute haben mittlerweile auch eine Festnetz-Flatrate, das heißt, die könnten einem dann sogar seinen Anschluss zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt, ich sag, ich komm jetzt mal aus dem Anschluss raus, denn mal wieder von woanders, geb jemand mal eine Nummer aus der Schweiz, mach dann einen Anruf Weiterleitung irgendwo anders hin. Und also man kann da ziemlich wilde Sachen bauen.
Ist das am Ende nicht so, dass man damit ganz wirkungsvoll unbedingt alle Verbindungsdaten verstecken könnte? Aber das ist natürlich so.
Man veranstaltet erst mal ein schönes Chaos.
Und wenn man zum Beispiel ein Stück dazwischen hat, wo man die Connection verliert, ist das eigentlich eine ganz gute Sache, um um die VDS-Wortsatenspeicherung rumzukommen.
Es gibt da noch die Möglichkeit, sozusagen private Netzwerke, Virtual Private Networks, VPNs zu machen, wo dann also auch nochmal die Daten auf der Strecke verschlüsselt sind. Das heißt, dass es dann auch wieder für niemanden möglich nachzuvollziehen, was da eigentlich rübergegangen ist über diese Leitung. So und wie gesagt, also je wilder man das hin und her strickt, je mehr Anbietermann involviert, mit mehr Freunden man das macht, desto unübersichtlicher wird das Ganze.
Das erhöht am Ende die Kosten für die Überwacher, weil sie natürlich dann jeden Schritt erstmal nachvollziehen können. Natürlich ist nicht wirkungsvoll, also das wollen wir auch nicht sagen, aber das ist eine Möglichkeit und wir versuchen halt beim Club auch gerade mal zu gucken, ja wie kann man das einfach machen für eine größere Anzahl von Leuten. Wir wissen, dass das im kommerziellen Bereich heute massiv eingesetzt wird, natürlich nur aus Kostengründen und also ich denke, da wird die Zukunft zumindest erstmal für die nächste Zeit hingehen. Immer mehr Asteriske.
Es gab ja auch in der letzten Zeit immer wieder diese Geschichte, dass es so eine SIM-Card-Tauschbörse gibt, dass man sozusagen, also ich schicke meine SIM-Karte irgendwo hin, kriege dafür die von jemand anderes und damit ist nicht mehr eindeutig zuordnenbar, wer jetzt da auf welchem Handy telefoniert. Das ist ja relativ schnell zusammengebrochen wieder.
Ja, also das war im Prinzip ja nur eine Woche am Netz, diese Idee mit dem Kartentausch, die wird auf privater Ebene jetzt zwar noch weitergeführt, aber der AK-Vorzeiten-Speicherung hat sich entschieden, davon Abstand zu nehmen und also wir at CCC waren doch eigentlich sehr froh, denn wir haben diese SIM-Kartentauschaktion eigentlich jetzt nicht sehr sinnvoll erachtet, einfach weil doch durch die eher kleine Anzahl, die der Karten getauscht werden und vor allen Dingen auch die Art, wie dort getauscht wird, auf keinen Fall tatsächlich in der Anonymität hergestellt wird und vor allem riesigendrohend für die Leute. Also etwa wenn man sich vorstellt, derjenige, der eben die eigene Karte dort bekommt, stellt irgendwas an und gerät unter Verdacht, dann kriegt man halt erstmal Ärger mit den Ermittlungsbehörden und für so eine Tauschkartenbörse müsste man die Leute wo doch erstmal sehr genau instruieren, wie sie es benutzen müssen.
Es gibt zu viele Wagepunkte.
Man hat schließlich bei einem Telefon die sogenannte E-Mail-Nummer, also eine Nummer, die das Telefon identifiziert. Eine nationale Nummer. Und die Leute müssten auf jeden Fall die neue Karte, die sie dort im Wege des Tausches bekommen haben, erstmal in ein neues Phone einstecken, sonst können sie ja schließlich gar nicht, sonst sind sie eh wieder identifizierbar und sie müssten auch ihre Telefongewohnheiten ändern.
Also wenn wir ganz kurz zurück, wir hatten ja mal Anfang Gesendung, hatte ich so ein bisschen dieses Bild aufgebaut mit diesem Netz, mit diesem Spinnennetz, dieses Software, wo man sich durchklicken kann, wo man diese ganzen Daten reinwirft. Und das wird ja da an dieser Tauschbörse, kann man es sich ja wunderbar vorstellen. Das heißt also, ich hab irgendwie ein Gerät, sozusagen eine Gerätekennung von einem Mobiltelefon. Dann sehe ich, okay, welche Karte war da drinne, wer hat sie danach gehabt? Ich sehe das und das heißt, ich kann also dieses Netz, dieses Tauschnetz wunderbar einfach mit dieser Software abbilden, mit ein paar Mausklicks. Und das ist eigentlich genau das Problem dabei. Und weil ich es ja auch noch dann zuorne, das heißt also, wenn ich davon ausgehe, dass mein Handy auch mit der neuen Karte dann auch wieder bei mir zu Hause liegen wird und mit den gleichen Nummern benutzt wird, also die gleichen Anschlüsse angerufen werden, so dann bringt es eigentlich nicht so viel. Im Gegenteil, es lässt sich mit so einer Software wunderbar ein gutes Bild erstellen, wer eigentlich gerade mit wem getauscht hat.
Dazu haben wir einen Anruf aus Berlin und zwar von Thorsten. Guten Abend, Thorsten.
Das Problem ist, ich vertausche oder verschicke meine IP-Adresse, ich vertausche meine Karte vom Pripyat. Was passiert, wenn Leute mit der von mir genutzten oder von dir verschickten Geschichte was anstellen?
Dann stellen die Bullen bei dir vor der Tür.
Ja, dann hast du das Problem und brauchst eine ziemlich gute Erklärung.
Also ist eigentlich auch diese Geschichte mit dieser E-Mail-Geschichte, dass ich über andere Leute was verschicke, genauso hin, vielleicht.
Also meinst du möglicherweise diese Tor-Geschichte, wenn du nicht andere IP-Adressen hast? Ja, genau. Ja, das ist richtig, da hast du recht. Also das hatte ich auch schon gesagt, wir hatten dieses Jahr eine große Durchsuchungswelle und es ist so, dass die Personen, die sogenannte Exit-Nodes betrieben haben, also quasi der letzte Punkt in dieser Kette waren, das war dann die IP-Adresse, die dann auch in den Protokolldateien aufgetaucht sind. Genau, der hat dann diesen Server hingestellt, hat gesagt, hier, ich finde das cool, will dabei sein, will das nutzen oder hier benutzt es. Und dann hat er eben morgens um sieben den Besuch bekommen, der Server wurde beschlagnahmt, war natürlich klar, dass da keine Logdaten drauf sind, weil das passiert einfach nicht. Es gibt Fallen bei diesen Tordiensten, fallen einfach keine Daten an, keine Protokolldateien, aber der hat halt erst mal den Ärger gehabt. Und da drüber muss man sich immer im Klaren sein. Deswegen machen wir das oder bieten wir das als Chaos Computer Club auch an, dass wir das sozusagen als juristische Personen das machen, dass wir diese Dienste betreiben und können das natürlich nicht alles selbst bezahlen, weil so ein Server muss gemietet werden, der kostet im Schnitt 100 Euro, möglicherweise ein bisschen mehr. Man muss ja auch mal einkalkulieren, dass mal einer irgendwie wegkommt oder muss dann auch mal im Zweifelsfall mal einen Anwalt bezahlen, wenn es irgendwo Ärger gibt. Deswegen versuchen wir das ja irgendwie durch Spenden zu finanzieren und bieten aber an, dass wir diese Server selber betreiben. Also quasi, dass da unsere Adresse, unser Clubbüro drinne steht, unsere Clubanschriften, dann könnt ihr da gerne Bronze um sieben aufgeben.
Wir haben einfach Routinen dafür entwickelt, weil wir eben selber Betreiber sind, wie wir dann mit so einem Anfragen umgehen. Nee, aber uns geht es auch darum, dass wir einen Pool bilden können. Also wir wollen versuchen, Leute, die eben nicht mehr privat sich trauen, quasi, dass sie sich an uns wenden können. Das ist so ein bisschen das Ziel der Sache.
Also es gibt ja natürlich neben den Privat-Usern, sag ich mal, Leute wie Rechtsanwälte, Ärzte, wir hatten es vorhin, Seelsorger, Pfarrer, wer auch immer, bei denen es wirklich dramatisch nicht nur in die Privatsphäre, sondern auch in die Arbeitswelt einschneidet, wenn ihre Kommunikationsdaten überwacht und ausgewertet werden, weil dann ist sozusagen weder das Arztgeheimnis, noch die Speigepflicht des Anwalts, noch sonst was gewährleistet.
Es ist sogar noch mehr. Es ist durchaus auch so, dass unsere Ermittlungsbehörden in Deutschland natürlich auch Anonymisierungsdienste benutzen. Das sagen sie auch ganz offen. Also es sind nicht nur die Vertrauensberufe, die wir so haben, die eben schon genannt ist, sondern durchaus auch die Ermittler selbst, die sich ja auch anonymisieren müssen.
Torsten, danke für den Einwand. Ich würde ganz schnell noch nach Lübeck schalten wollen, weil Michael steht hier und hat eine ganze Latte von Fragen. Hallo, Micha. Warte mal, ist Lübeck moin oder moin moin? Naja, weil ich habe mal gehört, wenn du sagst moin, ist es okay, wenn du sagst moin moin, ist es ein bisschen schwärzer.
Nee, dann magst du die Menschen eigentlich nicht.
Ah, das war die Oldenburger. Okay, Micha, schieß los.
Ja, wo wir jetzt gerade bei der Person waren, wer bleibt eigentlich verschont oder sind wirklich alle? Oder da sind wieder unbeliebene, alle unsere Abgeordneten außerhalb?
Die Abgeordneten sind ausgenommen, ja.
Also ansonsten, es betrifft natürlich erstmal jeden, also eine halbe Milliarde Europäer, jetzt nicht nur die Deutschen. Und also der, der kommuniziert ist erstmal natürlich dabei.
Also letztendlich kann der Telefonanbieter kann ja erstmal nicht wissen, dass es ein Abgeordneter ist.
Ja, aber wirklich die Dienststellen sind dann halt freigeschaltet davon.
Nee, nee, nee, also keine Blacklist, sie werden erstmal alle gespeichert. Und das Entscheidende ist dann, ob die Daten rausgerückt werden.
Genau, der Zugriff.
Ja, die, die noch eine Frage dazu. Was kostet eigentlich so ein Provider? Jetzt sag ich mal die Speicherung. Ich mein, sie haben sie ja zu Abrechnungszwecken, müssen sie ja sowieso speichern. Bei Fleetways entfällt das ja prinzipiell, aber das ist auch nicht dasselbe, was gespeichert wird.
Wobei, also was ich mir auch absagen lassen ist, also das Problem ist gar nicht mal das Daten speichern. Also ich wüsste, was irgendwie eine 500 Gigabyte Festplatte kostet, das ist nichts mehr. Das Problem ist, diese Daten tatsächlich auch, sag ich mal gerichtsfest oder beweisfest, also wirklich solide aufzubewahren und dann auch entsprechend diese Abfrageschnittstellen zur Verfügung zu stellen oder eben diese Prozeduren. Und es muss natürlich auch von juristischer Seite entsprechend begleitet werden, das heißt also allein die Kosten dann Juristen zu haben, der dann auch darüber wacht, was mit diesen Daten passiert. Das sind dann die Kosten, die wirklich ins Geld gehen.
Also es gibt natürlich eine gewisse Form von Entschädigung, die der Staat, den IS-Pista zahlen muss, und die Telekom-Modifikationsunternehmen, aber die Summe, die wir vorhin schon genannt haben, also dieser dreistellige Millionenbetrag, ist natürlich zunächst mal eine Investition, die die machen müssen.
Das ist für die Abfrage, ne? Da gibt es denn eine Entschädigung?
Nein, das ist sozusagen die Technik, also es ist ja nicht eine sehr ungenaue Zahl. Also das sind die Kosten für die für geschäftsfremde Zwecke installierte Technik.
Von welchen Datenmengen reden wir eigentlich, sag ich mal pro Tag oder pro Woche? Weil wenn ich überlege, was bei Google, da gab es ja irgendwo mal eine statistische Seite, wo Google mal gesagt hat, was für ein Traffic sie wirklich pro Stunde oder so haben.
Wir reden da glaube ich eher, wenn man es über das Jahr sieht, wir reden über Petabyte. Also das heißt, das ist der Schritt über Terabyte. Also im Jahr fällt da einiges an. Aber sicherlich die Kapazitäten bei den Anbieter sind heute auch schon hoch. Und es ist nicht mehr so teuer wie früher. Und es ist ja auch verteilt. Es fällt ja nicht an einer zentralen Stelle eben diese gesamten Daten an. Das wäre für den Staat auch nicht machbar. Sie müssen es ja eigentlich auf die Anbieter verteilen.
Und es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ein DSL-Anbieter, der muss ja jetzt nicht protokollieren, welche einzelne Webseite du klickst, sondern muss halt deine Einwahl protokollieren.
Ja, da haben wir im Vorfeld uns noch sehr intensiv darüber unterhalten. Wir sind nicht sicher, weil wir brasilitänischen Details erst noch in Erfahrung bringen können. Es gibt geteilte Aussagen.
Zumindest ein ganz großer Unterschied, ob ich URL speichere oder ob ich IP speichere.
Das ist richtig. Aber man kann, man muss schon sehen, dass auch die Betreiber ja Listen von IPs haben. Und auch das wäre sehr kritisch. Es ist unterschiedlich. Ich hab mich jetzt auch in Europa mal um mir sehen. Und da gibt es Wohlländer, die dieses konkret wollen. Also die Liste der angesurften URLs. In Deutschland können wir es einfach nicht mit Sicherheit sagen. Ich halte es persönlich nicht unbedingt für realistisch.
Wobei es da also nochmal wieder unklar ist, ob es jetzt der Serverbetreiber ist oder der Zugangsanbieter.
Dann ist die Sache eigentlich hinfällig, dass die jetzt die ganzen Sachen speichern. Weil da könnte ja auf dem einen Seite gleichzeitig eine linke Seite wie eine rechte Seite sein. Von einer politischen Orientierung. Dann ist ja auch hinfällig, ob da jetzt sich einer aufgeklickt hat. Dann haben die ja nur die IP. Dann wissen sie aber gar nicht, ob der zur rechten Szene gehört und vielleicht irgendwas plant oder was.
Die Idee ist, dass sie den Server beschlagnahmen, um den es geht. Und dann sozusagen da anhand dessen sehen, wo die Zugriffe waren. Wer zugegriffen hat über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und welche Seite er aufgerufen hat eben auch. Deswegen sollten auch verantwortungsvolle Webseitenbetreiber, Webserverbetreiber sollten ihr Logging einfach möglichst abschalten. Weil dann können die Behörden auch gar nicht in Versuchung kommen, einfach mal nachzufragen.
Man muss sich schon bewusst sein, dass die angesurften URLs heute in der Regel vier Tage bei dem Anbieter gespeichert werden. Das ist so die gängige Praxis, also für einen kurzen Bereich.
Michael, eine Frage kriegst du noch, weil sonst räumt die Zeit weg und Richard aus München hängt auch noch da und trammelt mit dem Fernseher.
Eine habe ich noch. Genau, Tor. Zwei habe ich noch.
Zwei kurze, los geht's.
Wie ist das mit Tor eigentlich? Wie sieht es aus? Wer hat Tor auch verpflichtet? Eventuell die hier?
Gute Frage. Gute Frage.
Ja, das ist eine sehr interessante Frage. Ich hatte noch nicht auf demselben Sender hier im RBB ein Gespräch mit dem Herrn Engers aus dem Justizministerium. Einer derjenigen, die das Gesetz zur Vorratszeitenspeicherung geschrieben haben. Und ich hatte die Gelegenheit, ihn gleich mal danach zu fragen. Oder auch, ob es in Zukunft geplant sein wird, die Anonymisierungsserver vielleicht zu verbieten. Denn technisch fallen diese Logdaten nicht an bei dem Tor Server. Und er wusste zunächst gar nicht, was ich ihn fragen wollte und sagte nur, ja, da steht im Gesetz, die müssen rausgegeben werden, dann müssen die rausgegeben werden. Und dann habe ich ihm also lang und breit erklärt, dass die technisch nicht anfallen. Und dann war, nachdem er so der Groschen dann fiel, seine Antwort im Grunde, ja, dann wird es natürlich verboten werden. Aber damit hat er natürlich nur gesagt, was der Gesetzgeber wohl in Zukunft planen wird. Wir beim CCC sehen es eigentlich momentan so, dass Anonymisierungsserver legal betrieben werden können.
Und wie sieht es jetzt eigentlich aus, wo wir gerade bei der wettlichen Geschichte sind, wie sieht es mit dem letzten Standsverfassungsgericht aus?
Hatten wir vorhin schon mal ganz kurz, also Sie haben sich jetzt geeinigt, wer zuständig ist oder wer welchen Teilaspekt der Klagen beantwortet, der der Klage bearbeitet.
Aber da ist natürlich die Frage, der Anonymisierungsserver ist da jetzt nicht angesprochen. Da geht es natürlich um viele wichtige, ganz allgemeine Fragen unserer Grundrechte. Klar. Also ich persönlich würde eine Wette machen, dass die gekippt wird.
Ich hoffe es. Micha, danke für den Anruf. Schönen Abend nach Lübeck. Und jetzt auch der Traum eines jeden Senders. Jetzt ganz von Norden, tief runter in Süden von Lübeck nach München. Hallo Richard. Du kriegst zwei Minuten.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage zu VPN Tunnelservices. Da gibt es ja so diverse Angebote, zum Beispiel von der schwedischen Piratenpartei Relax, nennt sich das und VPN Tunnel glaube ich aus England. Und zwar, wie, ob das irgendwie eine Alternative zum Beispiel wäre zu Tor, weil also gerade bei diesem Relax gibt es so ein Demo Angebot, habe ich mal ausprobiert und es funktioniert wunderbar, ist wahnsinnig schnell, also kein Unterschied und da wollte ich einfach mal fragen.
Prinzipiell ja, das heißt also, dass erst mal alle Verbindungen, die dahin gehen, dann sozusagen, ja, also du kommst ja auch mit deren IP Adresse raus. Die Frage ist, ob du denen soweit vertraust, dass die dann deine Daten entsprechend nicht rausgeben.
Okay, also das heißt, gut, den schwedischen Piraten würde ich da einigermaßen vertrauen.
Ja, aber nur ein eigener SSH VPN Tunnel ist ein guter SSH VPN Tunnel.
Okay, aber nicht jeder hat jetzt die technische Kompetenz dazu oder auch die Zeit, so was zu machen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also ich würde der Piratenpartei natürlich da irgendwie auch eher vertrauen als anderen Anbietern, aber dieses Vertrauen muss natürlich haben. Ende der Debatte, also so ist es nun mal.
Aber ist es ein guter Kompromiss vielleicht zwischen Sicherheit und Komfort, sag ich mal?
Ja, ach na ja, also komformäßig finde ich.
Also Tor ist schon ein Komfort, ist schon okay, ist halt nicht wahnsinnig schnell. Aber je mehr Leute mitmachen, desto mehr Server wir betreiben können, desto komfortabler, desto schneller.
Und wir sehen auch durchaus Möglichkeiten technologisch, wie sich das in Zukunft weiterentwickeln wird. Also es gibt halt im CTC auch durchaus zu den sogenannten I2P, also neue Projekte, wo man gucken kann, wie man anonyme Netzwerke aufbaut. Da wird sicherlich in Zukunft eine Menge passieren.
Und wir werden sicherlich auch an dieser Stelle im Laufe dieses Jahres noch das Öfteren darüber reden.
Wenn du dich dringend mal beteiligen möchtest, nicht wahr, such dir den Regionalkreis der CTC in der Nähe und schmeißt das Projekt an und programmiere.
Richard, wir hören von an, ich freu mich. Das war Chaosradio 131 heute zum Thema Ausbruch aus dem panoptischen Gefängnis.
Vielleicht noch mal eins, weil der Hinweis kam auch schon auf unserer Mitmachseite auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Das heißt natürlich nicht nur, dass wir jetzt alle ganz tolle technische Lösungen gefunden haben, dass wir uns jetzt zurücklehnen können und sagen, hey, macht doch eure Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Nein, das ist natürlich genau nach wie vor wichtig, dagegen zu protestieren, auf die Straße zu gehen, Briefe zu schreiben, mit Leuten zu sprechen. Diese Klage zu unterstützen, wenigstens moralisch dran denken, Daumen drücken, wie auch immer.
Mama erklären.
Mama erklären, genau. Also das heißt jetzt nicht, dass wir nur weil wir jetzt irgendwie...
Nur weil auf unserem Rechner Tor läuft, heißt es nicht, dass wir uns zurücksetzen und sagen, dann macht doch euren Scheiß alleine. Das wollte Frank eigentlich sagen, oder?
So ist es.
Alles klar. Ich würde gerne noch anmerken, dass unter Chaosradio.ccc.de diese und andere Sendung als Podcast zu hören sind. Wenn ihr euch zum Beispiel zum Thema GSM und GPS noch mehr anhören wollt, könnt ihr da gerne alles tun. Auch diese Sendung gibt es dort zu hören. Das Chaosradio gibt es wieder Ende Februar. Danke Konstanze, danke Frank. Hier geht es gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight und Smith & Smart. Schreibt ihr, schraubt die Radios fest. Bis denn. Haben wir noch was?